Dunwooch, a car.
As nuances.
A galera sofrer hoje em dia. Sendo bem honesto com vocês.
é sobre isso, porque existe muita coisa para estudar e constantemente as pessoas perguntam: o que estudar, o que vale A Pena O Que Não Vale A Pena.
Entendeu? Então assim.
Eu quero ter certeza que todo mundo que está aqui.
Vai ingerir realmente o conteúdo, que é extremamente importante, que está alinhado.
Com o que você.
Quebra sua carreira, principalmente.
Mas o que é realidade de você estudar?
Então a semana vai trazer.
Essa informação para você.
Eu acho que é uma informação na verdade muito válida.
Que ela vai te economizar. Ou talvez não te economizar, mas ela vai te colocar no caminho correto.
Eu acho que isso vale bastante.
Colocar no caminho correto é literalmente o campo, ou que realmente eu espero.
Que eu consigo fazer com vocês durante essa semana, tá.
Deixa eu só vir aqui.
Eu vou compartilhar minha tela em dois minutinhos, e a gente começa.
Só organizando aqui um emaranhado de coisas.
Beleza. Deixa eu compartilhar.
Minha tela.
Deixa, eu só ver o que vocês falaram aqui. Que estava prestando atenção em outra coisa.
Na prática, complicar sistemas agênicos. Dark Factory. Eu uso agentes diariamente.
Mas ainda precisa melhorar.
Oxigentes, perder fundamentos melhops.
Que não é mais o mesmo que tem por aí escolas que eu não sei exatamente isso. Obrigado, Ana.
Estará?
Apresentar, montar um agente autônomo.
Como capaz? Code, eleva o piso.
Engenharia. A gente expande o teto.
E o legal é que essas duas foram tragas por ele. Tanto o conceito de vibecoding como literalmente.
A ideia de engenharia genica.
Beleza. Vamos lá.
Quando estiver aparecendo aí.
Me avisa.
Apareceu e falam.
Ainda não.
If I need trouble no.
Hmm, should be.
Belieza.
Vê muito bem aqui. Eu vou estar acompanhando aqui do lado.
Como a gente vai fazer, tá? Então, para começar.
What was the most checkpoints contain speciala entrando.
Entender esse conceito como um todo.
E de vez em quando, eu chamo algumas pessoas como o Rafa está aí. Então chamo ele para trazer algumas Coisas Referentes à Experiência Dele Também Do Que Ele Tem Vivido.
No campo. Beleza.
E fiquem à vontade.
A gente tirar perguntas e respostas que são pertinentes no final.
O que ficar de dúvida que é mais genérica.
Sobre o seu ambiente, sobre.
Alguma dúvida específica que não foi sanada aqui.
Ideia é que a gente pergunte lá. No final, vou deixar um tempinho. Hoje. A gente tem duas horas, duas Horas E Vinte Mais Ou Menos De Aula.
E aí a gente tira isso no.
Beleza. Bem, o que a gente quer fazer na semana, então vamos entender por que a semana foi criada em Primeiro Momento A Semana Sempre é Criada Aqui Na Engenharia De Dados Academy.
Para trazer para vocês tudo que é de novo consolidado. Então essa é a primeira. A primeira grande questão.
Fazer com que vocês possam enxergar o mercado.
Do jeito com que nós, que estamos trabalhando ali.
Na frente, fora do país, com projetos realmente em escala de produção.
Possa ver. Tem muita coisa que sai no X. Tem muita coisa que sai de notícia. Tem muita coisa que Você Lê No Linkedin.
Mas a questão é, como que isso é pertinente. Se é pertinente, é como eu aplico isso no meu dia a dia.
Então a ideia da semana é a gente atacar um caso de uso.
E esse caso de uso vai mostrar para a gente. Vai trazer esse painel, e a gente vai gravitar em Cima De Um Problema.
E a gente vai navegar em cima disso.
Como eu tenho dito nos outros treinamentos, a grande ideia do ensino agora é literalmente ter cohorts de ensinamentos sobre Tópicos Específicos Então O Que Seria Isso.
A gente vai pegar uma semana aqui. A gente vai navegar no caso de uso.
E a gente vai aplicar todos esses conceitos dentro desse caso de uso.
Quem não só você vai aprender os fundamentos, mas você vai aprender na prática, como unir tudo isso.
Nesse treinamento. Se você quiser abrir o seu ln e seguir junto.
Você vai conseguir seguir cada dia junto. Porque eu criei uma estrutura que eu vou explicar para vocês.
Para que vocês possam literalmente entender.
Algumas coisas importantes aqui.
Algumas coisas. Eu vou navegar um pouco mais. Deep no fundamento. Algumas coisas. Eu vou um pouquinho mais rápido.
Então eu não vou conseguir. Eu não vou conseguir agradar todo mundo. Mas a ideia é o seguinte.
Durante cada parada.
Tenta tirar sua dúvida rapidinho.
E no final, tenta ali realmente sanar sua dúvida. Não conseguiu. Não deu tempo.
Amanhã a gente começa a aula. Dez, quinze minutos. Os dez primeiros quinze minutos aqui que a gente esperou. A Gente Vai Começar No Tempo Amanhã.
E você tira sua dúvida pertinente ao que ficou ali ou estude no final.
Uma das coisas que eu vou fazer também aqui importantes é no final. Quando você acordar ali, nove da manhã, dez da manhã.
Eu vou copiar o transcript dessa aula para dentro da pasta do repositório.
Eu vou deixar lá dentro, tá? Então você pode puxar no C llll em m e literalmente trabalhar com ela.
é muito importante que você entenda que algumas coisas, principalmente o seguinte: qual a perspectiva que a gente está começando? Isso aqui.
Está começando na perspectiva que você entenda.
Que hoje a gente primeiro.
Evita programar.
Evita escrever linha de cor.
Hoje, a gente evita não focar no que não é importante.
E quando eu falo, não é importante, abre se várias questões. Então, programar não é importante. Claro, tudo é muito importante.
O que a gente vai começar a ver é o seguinte: na escala de importância da entrega de um projeto.
Quais são as características chaves para você entender.
E para você colocar sua cabeça neste processo.
E é isso que eu quero mostrar para vocês. Onde é importante vocês olharem.
Então, na semana, a gente vai atacar um caso.
De uma companhia de uma empresa que a gente chama de transactico, que a gente vai aprender hoje aqui.
Que basicamente ela está lidando ali com problemas analíticos. Então eu tentei trazer um caso de uso.
Que engloba não só.
Que não engloba não só a parte de engenharia de dados.
Mas engloba parte de engenharia.
De software e que engloba também.
Engenharia de Analytics. Então a gente vai começar a ver agora que esse novo cargo que a gente fala, que A Gente Vê Bastante Que A Gente Vai Falar Um Pouquinho Aqui.
Ele tem se consolidado a virar uma coisa só. A tendência é que todo mundo tenha vários Skills.
Então, se isso não ficou claro para você, a ideia é que fique.
A gente vai ver qual contexto desse problema hoje.
A gente vai identificar o que uma verdade significa para as pessoas que perguntem para o sistema.
A gente vai, ao longo dessa semana desenvolver uma arquitetura.
Didátria housing com melhores práticas. Em cima disso, utilizando Ductb.
E Dbt, para que a gente possa fazer esse depoimento de todo local.
Obviamente, se a gente quiser mandar isso para não ver, a gente consegue fazer também. Tá, então a ideia que Eu Sempre Recomendo Trabalhar Com Sistemas Agênticos A Primeira Coisa é.
Tente a fazer com que tudo seja local. First.
O máximo que você pode para que você dê os contextos e as permissões necessárias para o seu agente trabalhar.
Dentro do seu ambiente ou dentro de um ambiente Docker condenizado.
Outra coisa que eu recomendo vocês fazerem.
Preste muita atenção. Fica com caneta aí. Toda vez que eu falar alguma coisa importante, anotem.
There esse tipo de coisa, para que vocês possam literalmente lembrar dessas chaves que eu vou trazer para vocês.
Que eu vou chamar isso de Nuggets. Alguns nuggets importantes para vocês.
Então, o que a gente vai ver hoje? A gente vai falar um pouquinho de Trump de contexto.
Amanhã já fala de Harness. Está um conceito muito importante. Como está acontecendo? Quais são as últimas atualizações sobre isso?
No dia três, a gente vai falar de execução.
Como que a gente constrói um sistema de atividades atômicas. Eu vou trazer.
Uma coisa muito legal para vocês. Que eu ainda não publiquei em nenhum lugar. Mas eu tenho utilizado isso há Mais De Quatro Meses Tá Todos Os Dias.
Então vou trazer para vocês como que eu trabalho com atividades atômicas extremamente exclusiva. Isso aqui.
Na quarta feira, na quinta feira, a gente vai falar de looping Engineering.
Então, como que a gente consegue criar um loop.
E aí vou trazer um pouco o Rafa, inclusive para falar um pouco de Ival.
Que eu acredito que seja o grande clímax do negócio loop e vol são grandes pontos hoje.
Whether Gdq hoje. Se você quiser ter um sistema no nível de inteligência que a gente tem hoje.
Ideia é você focar no Invol. Então Rafa vai falar um pouquinho sobre como construir bons evol como rastrear, como Literalmente Pensar Em Voz.
Da forma correta. O Rafa trabalha bastante com isso no dia a dia.
Porque o sistema dele precisa de perfeição.
Então a gente vai começar a entender que para que você possa validar o trabalho de um sistema agêntico que Vai Fazer Por Você.
Você precisa dar validações para ele, Vó. A uma característica muito grande.
E no último dia, a gente vai fechar com algumas coisas bem legais que eu não quero abrir aqui, mas Que Vale Muito A Pena.
Eu vou trazer algumas pessoas também.
Na sexta feira. Curtei bastante.
E vai ser um bate papo muito interessante sobre o que está acontecendo fora do mercado. E o que está transbordando aqui.
Para as empresas, já.
Então vou trazer alguns dos meus mentorados do Datasip. Eu vou trazer o Rafa. Eu vou trazer.
O algimar, possivelmente para falar um pouco de code review in depth.
Para falar realmente de sistemas que podem fazer code reviews de formas específicas. Então.
é um tipo de conversa que acredite. Você não quer perder.
O que mais me assusta positivamente, não. Para quem está aqui assistindo essa aula.
é que, se a gente olhar o mercado.
A gente está tendo os papéis se colidindo numa nova profissão.
Que é o que a gente chama de engenharia, higiene. Por isso que você está vendo a gente falar. Isso.
A gente esperou muito. Eu esperei bastante até chegar nesse ponto de falar com vocês sobre isso.
O que, literalmente, eu gostaria que isso se tornasse uma realidade plena.
Em cima do cenário como um todo para vir aqui falar com vocês.
Porque para quem me segue há bastante tempo, sabe que eu não trago absolutamente nada.
Que não seja extremamente alinhado com o que o mercado lá fora pede.
E que transborda aqui efetivamente.
Então, hoje, se a gente for olhar os papéis, a gente está falando de analista de dados.
De Analytics Engineer, de engenheiro de dados de.
Ai ou Agents Engineers está falando de Evol Engineer.
Que inclusive uma das coisas que eu lembro, o Rafa falando seis, sete meses atrás, ele falou: cara.
Eu acho que vai ter muito espaço sobre Wall Engineering nos próximos meses.
E aí uma das coisas que o Raven falou, que seria uma predição realmente tenha acontecido bastante. Tem cargos somente de Volks hoje.
Para ganhar muito bem fora do país, inclusive.
E arquiteto de solução, ou Solutions Architect. Então a ideia é a gente ter.
Todo esse glamburado, e você vai eventualmente aprender. A questão é.
Eu preciso aprender tudo. E aí a questão é The Body. Quanto mais você souber, melhor você vai ser.
Porque se a gente fizer.
Um fast forward dois anos.
O que resta para nós. Vocês acham que escrever código.
Eu acredito. Não sei se você acha isso também, Rafa. Eu acho que no final do dia, vai ser compilar a intenção.
E ter um conhecimento extremamente amplo, conseguir guiar.
O sistemas, as fábricas ou os sistemas agênticos, ou as infraestruturas de ar.
Para que elas possam literalmente fazer o que é necessário, como o Jaime falou, e eu concordo muito sobre isso.
Atitude e pensamento. E para ser uma cabeça pensante.
Eu digo que uma das coisas legais dessa cabeça pensante é você ser expostos a problemas diferentes. Então.
Nessa semana. Você tem a oportunidade de sair um pouco do seu status for.
E focar. São oito horas da noite, oito e vinte.
Toda vez que eu trago esse conteúdo, eu geralmente sempre estendo o horário.
You know what you just ignorar aqui.
Eu tento transformar esse processo do que seja cansativo, para que seja muito legal. Seja muito legal para todo mundo Aqui Conseguir Absorver Esse Conteúdo.
Então o que eu recomendo? Pensa assim na sua cabeça, cara?
Talvez vão ser quinze horas aqui que eu vou sair. Se eu prestar atenção.
Cara que eu vou absorver. Muita coisa legal que eu vou levar pra minha vida.
Então, assim, eu acho que quando a gente consome conteúdo de pessoas que vivem aquilo.
Né? A gente tem que ficar com muita atenção. é o que eu faço. Geralmente no meu dia a dia, quando tem alguém.
Que sabe mais do que eu falando. Eu vou prestar bastante atenção, porque eu quero capturar.
Exatamente o que ele está fazendo. Então eu vou tentar trazer para vocês tudo isso.
Para que a gente compile isso tudo dentro dessa semana.
Ok, pessoal, beleza. Então agora.
Deixa eu transicionar.
Tá. é.
Para a apresentação.
Então antes, para quem não me conhece, tá?
E aí? Deixa só saber aqui quem é a primeira vez, pessoal que está na semana ou que está assistindo uma aula comigo.
O que está aqui. Pela primeira vez.
Só porque eu tenho uma ideia de quantidade de pessoas.
Pessoas novas aqui. Digam aí.
Mostrem down aí para mim.
Legal.
Temos uma galerinha, né? Então deixa eu me apresentar aqui rapidinho para a gente poder começ.
O conteúdo. Tá? Então.
Meu nome é Luan. Eu comecei na carreira.
Fazem aproximadamente dezanove anos.
Eu comecei minha carreira como Dba.
They Don desde o início, e a minha identidade foi sempre focada em dados. Posteriormente.
If We, literalmente contratado para uma empresa canadense em dois mil e treze, para dois mil e catorze.
Então fazem quase doze em treze anos que eu trabalho por uma empresa canadense chamada.
Aonde atendi vários clientes.
You know. Eu fui literalmente galgando, né?
é uma evolução na carreira. E aí uma coisa muito importante de vocês entenderem.
é que você.
é o responsável por ditar o qu.
E aonde você quer chegar.
Porque eu lembro muito bem.
Em dois mil, três, dois mil, catorze. Que a minha cabeça era ser totalmente um bom dever.
E, eventualmente.
Uma evolução de ser um Dba. Eu entendi que a ideia era expandir um pouco para dados e conseguir olhar.
Isso de uma outra faceta.
Depois que eu fui para dados, eu comecei a entender que Cláudia era algo que estava explodindo.
Então a ideia foi tentar me capacitar para a Cloud.
Depois. Consequentemente.
Assumir um cargo de liderança de time.
Possivelmente, tipo um time de arquitetura.
E hoje, seu primeiro, literalmente da empresa, entre quinhentos pessoas.
A ser um engenheiro, agente, trabalhando direto.
Com os Fields, que são exatamente os.
Chief Technology Office da Pf, que vai direto para o Kent. Eu vou basicamente junto com eles.
Para fazer a implementação de sistemas extremamente críticos.
E quem ainda nunca foram implementados.
Então eu tenho um trabalho muito hoje no. No que eu falo em Cutting Edge, né? Quando a gente fala Cutting Edge.
A gente está falando de tecnologias de ponta. Eu digo além. Eu digo Blair em Edge, assim eu, como também O Rafael Tem Feito Muito Bleeding Edge Muito Que Está Na Frente Que Acabou De Lançar Graph Engineer.
Envol, mas não somente ler, mas como a gente implementa isso em sistemas.
Então você está aqui literalmente, como pessoa que vive, respira.
E trabalha isso, né? Por exemplo, um exemplo real disso.
Hoje. Eu estou há onze, quarenta, onze horas e quarenta dentro aqui no meu computador, trabalhando nisso.
Então, literalmente, eu vivo isso aqui todo dia, toda hora da minha vida.
Então você não está escutando dinheiro, guru não tá aqui. A gente realmente.
Fala e literalmente trabalha com isso.
Por que eu achei muito importante trazer essa semana da engenharia genica aqui. Muito importante, cara.
Pelos últimos projetos, que eu comecei a fazer.
Então projetos como, por exemplo, infrasight, onde a gente começou a utilizar Sdrc, que é o todo ciclo de vida de A.
De ciclo de vida de desenvolvimento. Mas para Iá, ou seja.
Em vez de eu escrever o código no Databrics. Pô, eu vou colocar um agente para escrever para mim, pô, se eu vou fazer o Deployment no Databrics, eu vou criar um Developer. Um Devops Engineer.
Para poder fazer isso para mim. Se eu vou validar o dado contra um sistema de fonte de bordo.
Pô. Eu vou colocar uma agente para fazer isso. Mas não só a gente. Eu vou criar. Eu vou criar Harness Assim Por Diante.
Depois. Eu também comecei a trabalhar muito com o Franklin Madson, que é uma empresa gigantesca fora do país.
Para entender um pouquinho como unir todas as informações dessa empresa e dar disponíveis. Isso.
Para um sistema a gente, para que eles possam consumir essas informações. Hoje, uma dor de cabeça muito grande.
A Kubik foi um dos maiores. E ainda é um dos maiores desafios ainda na minha carreira, que é.
Literalmente fazer a modernização de legado de Databrics. Jess Kelly para a Databrics.
conformadas y verificadas de systema.
are seen.
Evita.
A gente cria todo o processo para a gente. Faz deployment assim por diante. Tá.
Regent para que a gente possa criar um plano de controle onde os agentes possam.
Na verdade, as áreas possam fazer.
Demandas para a estagnósta, criar Harness e processos.
Para escrever esse sistema.
E por fim, Dan Ross também, que é um projeto que eu já fiz há um tempo atrás.
Que é criar um sistema de sentinela que valide e que entenda modificações no sistema.
No final do dia. O que eu quero mostrar para vocês aqui.
Que tudo hoje se torna a gente.
Porque o que um sistema agênico quer fazer é substituir.
Cabeças. é isso? Então, eu estava muito pensativo sobre isso. Falei: Cara, o que é o sistema agênico? No final do dia.
Então, cara, no final do dia, em vez de você ter, por exemplo, tem que traduzir, por exemplo, trezentos pulsídolas De Um Sk Server.
Para um Databrics. Quanto tempo você acha que isso vai demorar? Eu vou exercer o tempo. Vou esquecer tudo isso, tá? Imagina.
Complexidade de fazer isso. Imagina se eu tivesse um ano para fazer isso.
Posteriormente, a pisaria de dez, quinze a vinte engenheiros. Mas isso também não garante o sucesso por várias características, para Poder Ficar Aqui Horas Falando.
Mas uma delas é o conhecimento.
O conhecimento vive na cabeça das pessoas. Então, o que é um sistema agêntico no final do dia, cara? Um Sistema Agêntico Nada Mais é Do Que Um Replacement.
Para humanos, para cabeças de humanos. é isso. No final do dia, é literalmente isso.
Você tem Lms. Você tem toda a estrutura de prompt de contexto de Harness.
Literalmente de de loop, de voo e de graf.
Para que você possa.
No sentido máquina compilar um sistema inteligente e escalável ao ponto.
Em que possa fazer melhor do que humanos.
Com a couraça. Muito melhor. De forma muito mais rápida, com precisão. Muito melhor.
E assim por diante. Então, o que é um sistema agênico? é exatamente a substituições de nós, com os humanos, Para A Execução Das Tarefas.
Isso soa muito creep. Porque é creep.
Então, se você ainda fala as coisas na mão, se você ainda está digitando prompt.
Se você acha que o seu emprego não vai mudar, você está redundamente enganado. Ele vai mudar.
Tanto é que se a gente for olhar os Layoffs que já aconteceram, a gente está falando de mais de Duzentos Mil Layoffs Na área De Tecnologia.
Nos últimos sete meses.
E a gente está falando só de dois mil e vinte e seis.
Oito meses, na verdade. Então muita coisa está mudando, tá? E não é só fora do país, tá.
Dentro do país também. Então esse é o.
A gente aqui. Esse é a fundação base do que eu estou querendo que vocês entendam na semana.
E essa semana, para mim, na minha opinião, a gente já fez várias semanas.
Já fez semana de data volta a gente já fez semana de Data Breaks. A gente fez.
Semana de Prompt. Semana de áudio. Fizemos várias coisas.
Eu acredito fortemente que essa semana aqui.
Ela é a mais importante de todas. Porque a gente não está falando de um marco de tecnologia. Saca.
Que eu não estou falando agora que a gente está saindo, por exemplo, de ambiente on premises. A gente está Indo Para A Cláudio Que Foi Uma Big Wave.
Eu estou falando de um tsunami. Eu estou falando de um tsunami que muda completamente a perspectiva de como você Trabalha Como Você Pensa Como Você Faz Como Você Opera Como Tudo.
Ou seja, o ponto que você vai sair daqui é.
Não utilizeiá como ferramenta. Utilizá como literalmente você. Então é uma forma diferente de você pensar.
Então a gente vai emergir exatamente nessas nuances.
Para que nesses cinco dias você comece a experimentar. O que é.
Entender, pensar e ser criativo de forma agêntica.
é como a gente vai olhar um problema e a gente vai atacar isso de uma forma completamente diferente do Que A Gente Atacava.
A três, quatro anos atrás. Completamente. é uma outra forma. E com essa outra forma, a gente traz várias facilidades, Mas Também Te Traz O Quê.
Várias complexidades. Por isso que existe tudo isso.
Pronto. Contexto gráfico, telemetria e assim por diante. Arquitetura: porque a gente vai introduzir várias outros problemas que a gente não tinha.
E assim como qualquer passagem cíclica.
Not tecnologia. Você tem uma nova.
Coisa que acontece que vai melhorar uma série de coisas que vai trazer outras complexidades.
E a gente vai descobrir vários efeitos em relação a isso.
Antes de eu começar, temos três cem pessoas aqui. Mais de três, cem. Todo mundo entendeu? Bota o que aí? Só Para Saber Que Está Todo Mundo Vivo.
Prestando atenção para a gente poder começar aí um super conteúdo.
E mostra aí que vocês estão vivos, pessoal.
Eu acredito.
E geralmente, quando a gente começa, nós temos trezentos e trezentos e seis pessoas.
Tentem aguentar o máximo possível.
Que isso vai fazer a diferença?
Então a gente vai começar com a ideia do seguinte.
Muitos projetos.
Muitos.
Começam de um ambiente Brownfield.
O que é um ambiente Brownfield? Eu te explico o que é um ambiente Brownfield.
Você vai ver. Normalmente essas duas nomenclaturas muito.
Normalmente, quando você estiver participando de um projeto.
Ou você pode falar isso, tá? O que é um ambiente Greenfusion?
é um ambiente verde, tá sem nada.
Então, quando você está começando um novo projeto.
E você quer falar cara. A gente quer idealizar isso. A gente quer fazer isso e assim por diante.
Esse Will be Ancient Greenfield, que você não tem nada ainda realmente feito.
Esses tipos de projeto, eles tendem a ter tendências. Então a gente já tem muito uma ideia de pô. Eu Vou Começar De Forma Agêntica Agora.
Olha, poxa, eu vou começar literalmente a pensar em como utilizar Lms, agentes no Cloud Code, no codec, ou qualquer Sistema De Gente Que Você Utilize Ou Qualquer Ideia Qualquer Coisa Que Você Utilize.
Para escrever.
Agora uma outra dificuldade é você entrar num ambiente que já existe.
E, na minha opinião, muita coisa que você for fazer nos próximos anos, vão estar relacionados ao ambiente. Brown Field.
Vai ser um ambiente onde o cara fala. Olha, a gente tem esse repositório. A gente tem esse Sql Server. A Gente Tem Esse Post.
A gente tem expendente na nuvem. A gente tem esse ambiente on premises. A gente tem essa base de reggae.
A gente tem essa aplicação que precisa ser traduzida, sei lá, de.
Sei lá, de Python para Rust.
Whatever, tá? Então você vai começar a lidar com problemas que já existem.
E aí, a forma como que você aborda esses problemas são completamente diferentes. Porque a primeira ideia que você vai ter.
é tentar fazer o quê? Engenharia de Prompt. Você vai literalmente tentar explorar o codebay. Você vai tentar entender o Que Está Acontecendo E Isso é Extremamente Complexo Eu Vou Mostrar Para Vocês Aqui.
Algumas coisas muito, muito, muito erradas que nós fazemos.
E que, muitas das vezes, a gente não vê.
Então a gente vai passar por uma série de coisas aqui hoje.
Principalmente em como a gente.
Solidifica isso no final.
Então a gente vai ver vários conceitos aqui, né? E aí a ideia da semana é literalmente trazer para você.
A base que você precisa para entender porque.
Curti. Só. A realidade é a seguinte. Talvez você já esteja muito apressado para falar, cara. Mas tem uma Skill para isso.
Poxa, mas tem um framework para isso.
Poxa, mas tem já um modelo para isso. Eu não preciso saber. E a resposta é definitivamente você precisa saber.
Porque se você não entende o que é um period, o que é um Std? O que é um Idd? O Que é Um Bdd.
O que significa um Evol? Como você constrói isso? Enfim, quando você sair de um quilo.
E você for, por exemplo, com.
Um factory. Ou quando você quer se tornando de ferramentas. Quando você sair de um cloud Code e você for Para Um Codec Enfim.
Muitas das coisas estão atreladas. A ferramenta, que são features da ferramenta.
E que você não entende esse conceito. Então, primeiro, você precisa entender o que são as coisas. Poxa.
O que é literalmente um bom prompt, o que é um contexto.
Porque uma hora que você entende isso, você consegue.
Aprimorar o seu escopo e entender como você vai usar aquilo para resolver.
Um problema. Então aqui eu vou te dar um sinal de coisas. Ao longo desses cinco dias.
Para você no final, utilizar isso dentro do seu arsenal. Falar, cara. O Luan falou sobre isso.
Então, quando eu tiver passando por esse, vai ter escrito de tudo isso, né? Então, cara, injeta isso dentro de Uma Base Fala Cara.
Eu quero utilizar isso como referência, porque aqui eu vou cuspir basicamente tudo em cinco dias que eu já passei de forma resumida.
Então a questão é, pô o que funciona? Como funciona? Aonde isso está.
Quando que eu aplico isso como foi falado de camada de ontologia, o que é para que sempre.
Muita gente aqui nunca ouviu falar em ontologia?
Muita gente aqui acredita. Como eu também acreditava cegamente.
Que quando eu falo para o meu Llm, seja ele qual for.
Fala, cara. Faz uma pesquisa no Post Grossly e retorna para a minha quantidade de pedidos.
Ela foi lá e retornou a quantidade de pedidos. Você inspecionou a Sql.
E você viu que ele fez um ciclo count pô beleza. Ele fez, mas.
Será que ele consultou a tabela certa? Será que ele consultou o campo certo? Será que ele fez o filtro correto?
Esse é o grande problema hoje, é entender realmente a acurácia da informação que você está traduzindo. E voltando a isso.
Então isso é muito importante você entender nos dias de hoje, tá.
Então, antes da gente entrar no problema, eu quero deixar algumas coisas muito importantes e muito setadas aqui em pedra, Para Que Vocês Não Tenham Dúvida Nenhuma.
Então a primeira coisa que eu quero que vocês entendam.
El estreema muche necesaro.
Important.
Now motel.
Cloudy opus of fable.
de.
Experimentarament importante. Te estarament importante.
Novo.
Ja facies.
aqui.
2.
Ta.
A primera cuisa e suprami.
Now, me as soon.
Prof.
Moses.
a tariff.
Evidencia.
When the swings per 5o para para.
el moto.
Gente que.
discrito.
is upcoming.
Eso des es para voce que si vous effici nao de patafero vaita seo.
Oh, desk spec.
Quata.
A.
Ashti, Kara.
Solar.
E atomicas.
or project seeks operate.
amazing fucking return.
You don't surprise from your mind-blowing total.
Trace.
Uma codex20X.
Enquima Allegro.
Dr.
later on each.
Segundo da contesto.
Mente.
Key.
Ciudado es muyen.
de fundacao.
fetivo.
moment.
It doesn't sing.
Porque é onde está o dado. Então, se você pensar em todos os ringues onde o dado reside no contexto. Então Outro Ponto Importante.
O dado curado atual. E olha só.
São duas palavras que assim, puta. Desculpa o palavreado. São fodas de conseguir, tá? O dado curado é extremamente difícil.
E o dado atual é ainda mais difícil. Não é só trabalhar com.
Grafos. Não é só trabalhar com semântica. Não é só trabalhar com literalmente timestamp. Você precisa saber o que é Atual E O Que é Factível O Que Não é.
Para a unidade.
Para que o que você carregue no contexto tenha um sinal em vez de barulho.
Vocês vão entender muitas características disso na semana. Olha que loucura. Outro.
Autoridade. Então, outro ponto muito importante aqui. é privilégio que você dá de acesso. Como que você configura o seu ambiente.
Como que você feta, que a gente chama literalmente dos guard rails. Em relação a tudo isso.
Isso é outra coisa muito importante, por isso falo de tentar ser local. Forças.
Então.
Seu local. First te habilita com que você teste com que você dê acesso aos granulares com que você vai experimentando.
O processo como um todo. Beleza.
E por último, e aqui é uma coisa muito importante.
A prova como um todo. Que é.
Como que você garante.
E aquela informação é real.
Cara pensa comigo. Se você tem a entrada e você tem a saída.
Você tem o coração. Você consegue.
Você consegue construir qualquer coisa. Se você tem.
Literalmente o input. é o que a gente chama de Ground Truth.
Você tem a verdade absoluta. Então essa verdade absoluta faz com que você tenha dois pedaços e componentes extremamente importantes.
O que determina o seu projeto e o seu sucesso no projeto. Várias características, mas a primeira delas é.
Uma coisa que o Rafael fala e eu concordo. é, começa pequeno.
Não tenta questão. Boy the Ocean não tenta afogar o oceano com tanta informação. Então começa pequeno.
E o segundo e mais importante, na minha opinião, é telemetria. Como First Class Citizen.
Como primeiro, literalmente, ponto importante de você entender. Cara, eu tenho que ter telemetria em todas as partes do meu Processo Eu Quero Saber O Que Está Chamando Quanto Tempo Está Pensando O Que Está Fazendo.
Essa rastreabilidade vai te ajudar, principalmente depois, eventualmente, a modelar. E Walls também.
Para que você possa entender quais iguais eu vou colocar.
Quais são os Gates que eu vou parar?
Aonde eu vou estar? Como Human in the loop.
Onde o humano vai entrar, porque essa é uma parte interessante. Vocês ainda não entenderam que agora.
Não é mais tipo, cara, eu vou entrar em todo o processo. Não, você vai estar em alguns poucos processos.
O que vai diferenciar você de um outro cara. E aquela coisa sempre vai ser substituído por uma Ya, você Vai Ser Substituído Por Alguém Que Sabe Ya Melhor Que Você.
é literalmente o ponto aonde eu digo para você. é o seguinte. Você vai ter que entender aonde você entra no loop.
E aí, quando a gente começa a entrar nesse mix inteiro, o que a gente começa a ver.
A gente começa a ver o desenho.
De uma nova profissão.
Sendo criada no mercado.
Que engole e que torna com que tudo isso que a gente aprendeu aos longos de dez, vinte, trinta anos De Carreira Se Torna Uma Skill Olha Que Loucura.
E eu odeio falar isso, mas é verdade. Por exemplo, há dois anos atrás, existia o Prompt Engineer.
Atualmente existe o Evival Engineer. Você realmente acredita que o Evol Engineer vai existir durante dez anos? Daqui para frente, Não Vai Ser Literalmente Uma Outra Skill.
Que vai ser incorporada dentro de um engenheiro nativo de Iá.
Porque, eventualmente.
Todas essas coisas que a gente cria em volta do processo como um todo, são extremamente marcantes e importantes.
Elas vão ser automatizadas pelo processo em si.
Tanto. é verdade que se você ler sobre o Deep Sick Flash, se você ler sobre o Química, tres.
Se você ler sobre o Cloud cinco e Fable cinco, o que você vai ver.
é literalmente as melhores práticas. Te instruindo. O quê? O reverso velho.
Antigamente, você precisava ditar o Claudia Md. Você precisa passar objetivos muito claros. Você precisaria dar passos do que é Executado Em Grandes Escalas.
Hoje. O que o time fala o seguinte, cara.
Deixa o Llm pensar.
That Pray as características principais e deixa ele fazer reasoning, porque ele é perfeito nisso.
E realmente é verdade.
Se a gente testar esse em grande escala. E se você testa isso todo dia.
é.
Você começa a ter essas informações como um todo, né?
E aí, por exemplo, um ponto importante que o Igor falou aqui. Todas as Harness produzem o mesmo resultado.
Depende. Sim, obviamente produzem, por exemplo, depende do caso, né? Se eu quero, por exemplo, que um Http responda no duzentos, ok.
Então Deus pode me retornar duzentos. Ok, agora, o que está lá dentro?
Então existe, obviamente, quando eu falo sobre retornar o mesmo outcome.
é como você tem uma tarefa muito bem definida.
E você exatamente sabe o que você quer.
Quando você tem essa informação, e você olha os leites Models. Basicamente, você vai ter a mesma entrega.
Uma das coisas que vocês podem testar em ambientes multi Harness. E a gente vai ver diferença de várias coisas. é.
A mensagem, não o conteúdo.
Então essa é a grande questão. às vezes, a gente pede para construir alguma coisa, e cada Llm vai construir De Uma Forma Diferente.
A questão é.
Beleza. Vocês inscreveram de várias formas. Nós chegamos no mesmo alto, cama.
Cheguei. Então, para a perspectiva do que é completo, é o quê? Então, o que é interessante? Entender é exatamente O Que Eu Falei Por Debaixo De Todas Essas Palavras A Intenção.
Então, se você aprende a compilar a intenção, e você passa isso para a máquina, você começa a ter um resultado extremamente satisfatório.
Então a gente está vendo que tudo acaba virando.
Uma Skill, obviamente em grandes escalas. E o que é importante a gente entender aqui.
Que gente como engenheiros nativos, beleza.
Vai começar a transbordar aqui dentro.
E uma das coisas reais que tem acontecido é que a profissão que mais cresce no mercado hoje.
é o que a gente chama de forward Deploy Engineer ou ai engineer or ai, Applied Engineer.
Whatever. Mas o que mais existe em relação à velocidade.
Se chama de Fd, que é o Floor Deploy Engineer.
Tá? O que que é esse forward to Our Engineer? Isso foi uma, na verdade, uma role que foi criada Pela Palantier Duas Décadas Atrás Basicamente.
Que a ideia é porque eles trabalhavam no governo. Então o que eles tinham que fazer é, eles treinavam.
Tecnicamente, os engenheiros e eles Deploy, esse engenheiro dentro do governo.
Então.
Esse engenheiro precisava literalmente entender toda a parte tecnológica, para poder fazer com que um projeto, um processo funcionasse.
E ele precisaria estar deployed dentro do governo, porque existem regras de segurança, cartões de acesso assim por diante.
Essa ideia do Four Deploy Engineer. Ele justamente existe por causa disso. E quando a gente vai no mercado lá fora.
é o que a gente mais vê. Então vocês já podem literalmente começar a dar uma olhadinha no Linkedin sobre Four. Depo.
Sobre as características de For the Engineer. Você vai ver muito sobre Ai Fdi.
Né? Que é o Ai for deploy Engineer, ou somente a for deploy Engineer. Enfim, tá. Então a ideia é Que Hoje A Gente, Tem Uma Dominação Muito Grande Dessas Rolls.
E quando a gente olha muito. O que é esse cara?
A gente está olhando justamente ao processo de evolução do que eu expliquei aqui atrás.
Obviamente que agora vai ficar gostoso. Quem sabe mais.
Teoricamente, tem maior vantagem competitiva, como sempre.
Mas agora a gente está indo para um ambiente muito mais difícil, né?
Que agora você tem que entender sobre software. Você tem que entender sobre ai Engineer. Sobre Daily Engineer, semanal Engineer da Vops.
sistema.
Pricing could have fallen on the key.
Voce escutarana.
Para, selecting augenoje que facales.
I think, for example, amigo de vinci alcohol.
Tamo si.
sempre da.
Y esa muy importante.
Etoc eu todente necesar e mutuzano. Ponto naare de Constoria.
Obremente que esten casos de casos. Nebeno qualifa pocha.
No.
One. é isso?
Então, assim, se vocês ainda não entenderam o que são os sistemas agênicos? São.
Bilhões de seres humanos com base de conhecimentos dentro deles, os mais treinados experts do mundo.
Dentro de um problema, fazendo isso de uma forma extremamente rápida.
Em nível máquina. é isso, velho.
é isso? Você está assistindo? Você está criando um sistema de ético para isso.
O que é um sistema de multi agents.
é o Luan, que é um bom arquiteto de solução.
Yeah, Renata, que é um bom engenheiro de dados. é o Rafael que é um bom. Ai Engineer. é a Juliana Que é Uma ótima Software Engineer.
E a gente usa todos esses. Configurar e fazer alguma coisa. Agora, imagina a frota de duzentos, trezentos quinhentos.
E a gente começa a expandir. Esse escuro. Não é.
Imagina quando estiver falando de computação quântica. Imagina quando a gente vai falando de modelos.
Literalmente que, como já acontece, né?
Que se treinam, né? Que se auto melhoram ao longo do tempo. Então essa é a grande ideia.
E aí a gente começa a ver os passos disso, né?
Então a gente começa a olhar o Prompt e vê, cara, será que o Prompt hoje é o The Thing? Não Hoje Não é.
Hoje. Você não deve escrever prompt.
Escrever Prompt é muito dois mil e vinte e cinco Setembro, Outubro. A gente não escreve mais prompt.
Duas coisas que a gente faz. Ou a gente fala com a máquina.
E essa interpretação é melhorada para ser enviada.
Ou você cria um sistema que recebe o que você fala.
E esses termos se encarrega de fazer o Prompt para os agentes.
Você não deve ficar mais digitando prompt. Você está perdendo tempo.
A velocidade de você falar. é muito mais do que você escrever fora os outros benefícios que você tem de Forma Cognitiva Por Exemplo.
Então, por exemplo, hoje eu passo noventa do meu dia falando.
Com as minhas sessões do que digitando com elas.
Então, uma das formas de você entender que prompt é importante você entender o contexto como um todo. é claro.
Mas é algo que você deve focar. Claro que não. Porque hoje a gente já tem essa abstração dentro de um looping.
Contexto.
Está vendo aí, exatamente? Você está na semana justamente para entender o que é essencial.
Contexto, por exemplo, poxa contexto é uma coisa para você gastar muito tempo estudando.
Mas pode gastar assim tranquilamente.
Tranquilamente, porque contexto é rei e sempre vai ser, porque é onde o dado está.
Depois, Harness pô. A gente começou a falar de Harness há seis, sete meses atrás.
De uma forma completamente diferente do que é hoje. Hoje, a gente fala de multiharness. Hoje, a gente fala de Um Sistema Que Faz Metaharness.
Que poxa, independentemente se é cloud code. Se é codec, se é Kim, ele tenta literalmente fazer isso.
Um bom exemplo disso é o My pai, por exemplo.
Não sei quem já usou. Oh, My Pie. Inclusive eu. Recebi de uma das recomendações da galera do Datasip.
E cara. Impressionante.
Eu diria mínimo, tenha utilizado bastante para algumas coisas. E tem ficado extremamente surpreendido.
O que ele faz. Então ele é meio que um Metahgness.
Então você basicamente tem uma Ide que se conecta uma ideia que se conecta com vários modelos.
E ele é um Harness que controla tudo isso.
Então você coloca ali o Cloud Code. Você coloca.
De psique ou qualquer modelo, realmente você pode conectar até com. Inclusive foi o Bruno.
Que me falou, né? Que eu comecei a pesquisar um pouquinho sobre.
Testar alguns metahartners, começar a ver cara.
Como que eu estou vendo essa parte de meta acontecer.
E cara. Sinceramente, até agora.
O mais legal de todos que eu achei.
Definitivamente esse cara é um cara interessante para olhar.
Tá. é.
Muito bom. Gostei bastante. Tá?
E a gente que, né? Então se começa olhar assim, ó.
E hoje eu estava fazendo inclusive uma apresentação para uma empresa sobre isso. Foi engraçado.
But carmas para que tudo isso, então, na verdade, é só por causa da característica, como um todo.
Então, por exemplo, Prompt Spec Velho. Olha onde está. Prompt Spec Prompt Spec. Está bem.
Bem perto.
é bem pertinho do modelo.
Então prompt é quando você está fazendo muito Wide coding, quando você tem ainda muitas coisas que não estão estruturadas na sua cabeça.
Alô. Eu vou ter projetos que eu uso. Webcode vai com certeza vai ter ambientes que você vai utilizar. Vibe Coding.
Mas quando você está indo para um modelo Enterprise, quando você está indo para uma entrega de times, quando você Está Trabalhando De Forma Colaborativa.
Não é? Vibe, code que você vai usar. Você vai começar com Spec Speck. é o primeiro passo.
Spect*driven development. Você vai criar ali, literalmente, qual o problema? Você vai dar o contexto.
Vai transformar o requisito de negócio técnico. Vai.
Fazer com que a arquitetura seja criada e vai literalmente pedir para os agentes.
Is evitarem aquelas tarefas que ainda não são atômicas, mas são muito importantes.
Então o Spec Driven Development te dá todo esse consenso, esse processo, fim a fim.
Dessas cadeias de execução. E a gente pode utilizar várias características aqui, né?
A gente tem o Github Spec Kit. A gente tem um Open Spec.
A gente tem algumas coisas que fazem similares a isso com o Bimed. Enfim, tem vários frameworks ali. Que fazem Esse Tipo De Coisa.
Inclusive a gente criou, né? Eu criei um cara chamado.
Agent Spec também. Que faz isso baseado em contexto.
Faz isso baldeado em subjetivos. Então.
Então é início pessoal do rolê.
Depois disso, a gente tem um contexto. Pô beleza. Quando eu vou criar o Spec inteiro, eu preciso prover um Contexto Do Que é Da Minha Empresa.
E cara quando está falando de contexto, a gente está falando de uma.
Aceitada de coisas. Depois eu vou prover um Harmness para ele, né?
Quais são as ferramentas? Quais são as permissões que ele tem? Qual estado que ele está? O que ele pode consultar?
Com a capacidade dele se recuperar entre sessões. Por exemplo, poxa, eu estava em uma sessão no Codeex. Pô agora Eu Quero Inicializar Uma Sessão No Cloud.
Pô como que essas informações, como esses sinais.
Começa a descoberta acontece. Então, quando você está começando a trabalhar com Harness, você está começando a pensar nisso.
Beleza. E quando você vai em loop, você está citando um objetivo. Você está utilizando a característica de literalmente de Um Llm Ali No Sistema Gênico Que é.
Literalmente.
Agir, observar.
Decidi repetir. Então ele está fazendo isso.
Depois disso, eu estou indo para e voz.
Então olha só e volta lá em cima, cara. Eu tô tendo um Acceptance Criteria. Eu tô tendo maior autoridade.
Eu estou tendo um nível de suporte de decisão.
Eu estou literalmente aprendendo.
Tendo e dando responsabilidade nesse processos específicos que eu quero.
E por fim, a gente tem esse conceito agora, de Graph Engineering, né?
Que é a ideia de você criar vários loops ali, ou vários projetos onde você tem esse processo de governança.
Então você transforma toda essa cadeia num gráfico, e você agenda esse gráfico, esse gráfico passa por vários processos. Então.
O gráfico. Ele vai olhar. Poxa.
Eu recebi essa informação.
Aqui. Eu vou fazer isso aqui daqui. Eu vou fazer um invbol desse Evol. Eu vou executar um looping.
Vou consultar um contexto desse contexto. Eu vou acionar um multiharness que pode ser cloud, por exemplo, ou Kimi.
Disso que eu vou ler.
Esse Prompt que eu recebi. E daí? Eu vou pedir para o modelo executar. Então isso é um gráfico.
Ficou. Crystal Clear foda, ficou legal.
Eu gosto muito desses anéis. Eles ajudam muito a eu entender.
Aonde está cada coisa aqui. Beleza.
Já, já é Opa, tá.
Alguma pergunta?
Referente ao que eu expliquei.
Curta, tá? Não é dúvida sobre esse ambiente, sobre o que fazer. Enfim, só para o final.
Alguma dúvida referente ao conteúdo que eu passei.
E avisem se quiserem levantar a mão. A hora é agora.
O grafo. ô Igor. Ele é uma Deg. Basicamente.
Tá, então.
Basicamente, ele é uma Dec.
Então imagina que você compilou várias intenções ali. O que você quer fazer? No final do dia, ele vai gerar Uma Deg Pra Você Ele Vai Executar Essa Deg Pra Ti.
Tá.
Então, em dúvida, se eu vou continuar empregado nos próximos seis meses com essa brincadeira, aí depende da sua empresa. Depende Do Momento Em Que Ela Vive Depende.
De vários fatores.
A ideia não é olhar para isso aqui e falar. Pô.
Eu não faço Graph Engineer. Então eu estou morto. Ou poxa, eu não faço Harness Engineer. Então eu estou morto, né?
Você tem que entender que eventualmente, posteriormente você vai estar morto. Obviamente.
Porque vai ter outra pessoa que vai fazer melhor que você.
A questão é poxa, como eu aprendo isso. Como que eu entendo como isso tudo funciona. E como eu aplico isso na prática.
Porque eventualmente, um ponto vai te levando ao outro. Você vai entendendo. Vai aprendendo. Vai melhorando. Vai falando. Pô legal. Fiz O Spec Aprendi Spec Depois Pô.
Contexto. Como que eu consulto contexto, pô, vou na base. Como que eu crio isso. E você vai pesquisar.
Depois pouco, nunca faço Harness. E aí você vai evoluindo em cada uma dessas camadas e entendendo principalmente.
Qual é o caso de uso? Porque, diferentemente do que as pessoas vão te falar, que você tem que entender é O Seguinte Cara.
Eu vou usar tudo sempre. Claro que não. Isso aqui é literalmente é o seu cinturão. Onde você vai pegar cada problema desse.
Quando você vai pegar cada coisa dessa? Como você tem um problema para atender.
Poxa, quando é um problema de Spec. Olha só os nuggets que eu já estou colocando na cabeça de vocês.
Para que eu uso Spec.
Cara, seus Specs. Principalmente hoje.
Para desenvolver algo sério.
Algo que tem estrutura, algo que seja em Times.
Para que eu uso contexto para buscar o contexto. Do que você vai desenvolver da sua empresa.
Então pô, eu tenho uma base Skipserver. Eu tenho um Mongo. Db: Eu tenho documentos da empresa. Eu vou curar Essa Informação Vou Deixar Disponível.
Para que na hora que eu esteja criando Spec, criando o prompt, ele vai lá e fala. Olha esse termo Aqui Que Você Usou Que Você Quer Criar Verdade.
Na base de dados, que é a tradução daquele arquivo. Com aquele. Tem um texto.
Pô beleza. Agora eu tenho uma informação. Eu tenho Spec bem escrito. Eu tenho um contexto que eu ingeri.
O que é o Harness? Pô beleza. Vamos executar agora, antes de você executar.
Eu preciso te dar. Quais são as ferramentas que você tem acesso? Por exemplo, você tem acesso de ler um Sql Server.
Você tem o acesso de fazer um Deployment Data Brics.
Eu tenho acesso de literalmente consultar uma base de dados. Você pode escrever numa tabela? São as permissões que você tem.
Outra coisa. Eu guardo o estado dessa informação se ela mudar. Enfim, eu guardo o State para entender.
O que aconteceu depois. Poxa, agora eu vou literalmente falar. Olha.
Dado tudo isso cria essa atividade. Executa esse grupo de atividades. Para mim, ele vai ficar fazendo looping disso.
Até literalmente, ele concluir, baseado no objetivo que você deu.
Só que depois você tem que validar. Olha só. Eu traduzi um código de Sql para Python.
Mas como que eu sei que o resultado final está certo?
Eu tenho que ter alguma coisa que valide essa informação.
Poxa. Vale do Código. Beleza vale o código.
Pô vale do dado do resultado. Pô, é diferente. Eu tenho que ver um sistema da fonte para verificar isso.
E no final, quero automatizar todo esse processo e criar um processo em que, olha que coisa linda que eu Vou Ensinar Para Vocês Olha Que Coisa Foda Hoje Vocês Vão Aprender.
Quem aqui já faz isso. Eu duvido. Se tiver alguém, seja sincero.
Hoje eu tenho um processo de Ci.
Que toda vez que eu faço um convite.
No repositório, na Master ou na Mem.
Ele ativo Ci de gráfo.
Que usa o Ofk, que é o padrão.
De Google, para poder atualizar todas as documentações e todas as referências, projetos.
Esse é um Graph Engine. Ele verifica todas as características. Todo o projeto faz isso.
Então isso é uma forma de você utilizar cada pedaço dele.
Então, só pra vocês entenderem, como que cada um desses projetos, esse processo, ele vai entrando na necessidade que você Tem Então Fica Tranquilo.
Eu preciso saber isso.
Muito bom você saber. Mas melhor ainda é você saber. Dois meses, você sabe implementar do que você falar que Sabe Dez E Você Não Sabe Implementar Absolutamente Nenhum.
Então a grande ideia é você entender cada caso de uso dele.
Dúvida para o grafo. Foi muito rápido pelo Boris Anthropico. Como o grafo detecta o que ele deve acionar.
Time de agentes.
Por eso.
Peles?
Caro.
aqui.
Ficudade.
One size fits all noises.
Meis.
Buenoit.
Pra fora…
Yes, esa parto grafo, do comfers que pramifico de pento un poco bistrato. Someto ascende apente y pra pratica, na. A eu queria de pente lasaduro
Você, se vai ter, alguma, etapa, algum processo aí, que de, repente você vai mostrar para a gente.
Sim, eu vou explicar. Eu vou explicar sobre gráfico.
Você, vai passar por todos esses, anéis em, algum processo e mostrar pra gente.
Vou falar durante a semana inteira. Vou passar por cada um deles.
Sim.
Tranquilo beleza.
Beleza. O Jamesson me perguntou quantos por cento você tinha usado o Agents Spec no seu dia a dia.
Já que entraram novos modelos, você sentiu. Enfim.
Hoje eu uso zero do Agents Spec hoje eu não uso mais Agents Spec, pelo menos para os projetos que eu estou.
Mas cada um existe a sua necessidade. Porque o projeto que eu. Que eu literalmente trabalho hoje.
Eu já estou a um nível de compilar a intenção. Então, pouco diferente ali.
Do que literalmente, o Agent Spec se propõe a fazer.
Entretanto.
O Spec como um todo. é a grande característica principal. Tá.
Então essa é a grande ideia.
Deixa eu seguir. Então.
Beleza. Então a gente vai começar a pensar num sistema como um todo. Então, a primeira coisa que a gente Vai Começar A Ver Aqui é O Seguinte Cara Na Vida Real.
O que a gente quer fazer. A gente literalmente.
Que é ou.
Nesse contexto. Aqui a gente foi entrar num sistema.
Que a gente não conhece. Então, qual a forma de fazer isso? Então, o que a gente vai explorar é um sistema.
Que tem um front que escreve dentro de um deck que escreve ali dentro de um Daily Store dentro de um database.
E a gente tem Analytics que rodam em cima disso.
Porque o Cfo, né? Que é o cara do dinheiro. Ele quer literalmente saber.
Quanto realmente ele tem de vendas.
E essa é uma coisa que eu trabalho.
E eu vou trazer esse caso do uso porque ele está totalmente atrelado ao que eu vivo no meu dia a dia. Hoje.
Que é. Existe algo mais crítico do que dinheiro e precisão? Não, não tem. Então, para vocês terem ideia como Que A Gente Consegue Visar Um Sistema Gênico Para Esse Tipo De Coisa.
E como que a gente consegue entender sobre isso. A primeira coisa é o seguinte.
Olha só. Que loucura. E aqui são os Nuggets que eu quero que vocês anotem. Que vocês estejam na cabeça Quando Vocês Estiverem Escutando O Que Eu Estou Falando.
Olha só o relatório. Pode ser preciso.
Olha só. Que loucura. O relatório. E eu passei por isso.
O relatório pode ser preciso e pode ser errado.
Concorda comigo. às vezes, a gente não pensa assim, mas pode. Olha só. Que loucura louca.
Precisão.
é uma coisa. Está certo. é outra.
Olha só. E isso foi uma coisa engraçada que eu passei, inclusive no cliente. Cara, tá aqui todos os pedidos Badalhinhos Tá Extremamente Complexo Ele Falou Cara Mas Está Errado.
Eu falei: Por quê não? Porque, olha só, você fez um cálculo aqui.
Onde você considera, né? Baseado no Current Date, menos um ali.
Todas as vendas. Só que tem um pequeno detalhe no meu negócio.
A gente só considera.
Status que foram entregues.
Agora deixa eu perguntar uma coisa para você.
E quando você pede para ele fazer isso, ela sabe disso.
Ela não sabe disso. Então, assim a primeira coisa que eu vejo, a galera.
Se extrapolar inteira. Quando ela começa a utilizar llms Cloud Codecs.
Por que seja. é.
Assumptions. Ah, eu acho. Ah, eu entendi que.
Cara. Essa é a forma.
Anti Engineer disse.
Você precisa realmente entender.
O sistema. E você nunca vai ser um bom profissional. Nunca. Eu vivo falando isso. E eu vou repetir para vocês aqui.
Novos velhos que já assistem isso. Você nunca vai ser um bom profissional.
Se você primeiro não souber os fundamentos.
Segundo, não passar muito tempo.
Do que mais importa hoje.
Escrever código hoje. Deixa a gente fazer.
Automatizar o pipeline, deixo a gente fazer.
Escrever as nuances de qual melhor design Pattern instrui o que ele quer e deixa ele fazer.
Garantir que os agentes estão seguindo o design Pattern Opa. Você no loop.
Garantir que você entende a intenção do que tem que ser feito ou não. Opa, você não luta.
Entender qual é o problema.
Você cem por cento no loop. Então agora o que você começa a fazer é cada vez mais tirar.
Você do loop.
Do que não é mais importante. Lembra que eu falei lá no começo? Que codificar não é mais importante.
Não é porque quando você olha.
O esquema como um todo.
Você vai se comunicar com o Cfo? Quantos anos você, como engenheiro de dados, demorou para conversar com o Cfo?
Quando você vai chegar no nível do Cfo? Você está fazendo exatamente isso aqui. Por quê? Porque você não entende Do Sistema Ou Seja Quem Vai Liderar O Mercado.
Quem souber tecnologia e negócio. Se você ainda não entendeu isso, eu estou deixando claro para você.
Quem souber. Tecnologia, negócio.
Literalmente vai ditar o jogo, mas sem sombra de dúvida. E eu gostaria de poder falar coisas para vocês que Eu Não Posso Infelizmente Mas.
Essa é a maior verdade. Se você entende o negócio do cliente, você entende tecnologia, amigão. Você vai ganhar muito Dinheiro Não Tem Nem Como Ser Diferente Disso Nem Como Nem Se Você Quisesse.
Tá.
Quando você fala com o Cfo, o que é importante saber.
Obviamente coisas de Cfo things como finob, esse tipo de coisa. Mas eu acho que o mais importante não é se atrelar.
Ao título. Essa até lá.
A como a pessoa quer receber e como ela ingere informação.
Então, toda vez que eu estou conversando com qualquer nível de pessoa, eu tenho algumas perguntas que eu faço para Entender A Mente Daquela Pessoa.
Eu quero entender como que ela responde. Se ela é uma pessoa.
Críticas. Ela uma pessoa mais rápida. Se ela gosta de coisas que são feitas com mais velocidade, se ela gosta De Coisas Mais Detalhadas.
Como que ela se comunica comigo. A melhor forma de você entregar valor para alguém é você não deixar ela Pensar Demais No Que Você Manda Para Ela.
Então, se você levar isso para a cabeça de vocês e entendeu, a mensagem é o seguinte.
Se o Luan se comunica por Ppt, você se comunica com o Luan por Ppt.
Se o Ayrton se comunica, via.
Mil linhas de código.
De engenharia de software com design patting.
Se comunique com ele dessa forma. Então você tem que identificar isso de pessoa para pessoa.
Você precisa entender. Para impactar as pessoas como que você vai fazer. E a melhor forma de impactar uma pessoa hoje.
é fazer o que ninguém faz.
é só ter carinho e entender o que essa pessoa quer. Só isso. Hoje, a galera quer cuspir coisa de Ar Fazer Jogar Para Um Lado Fazer Para O Outro.
Gera qualquer coisa, cara. Se você botar carinho numa entrega, e você literalmente direcionar. Para quem você está falando? Com Quem Você Está Falando Como Você Vai Entregar A Mensagem.
Isso já é setenta do caminhão. Dá.
Então, aqui está a questão.
Você tem uma qualérie que literalmente é um Sql cem válido.
However. Entretanto, você tem uma disposição de um dois milhões aqui.
Mas essas três Little Transactions aqui.
Uma foi cancelada. Uma foi refundada e uma está Pending. Mas na verdade, ela está dentro da tabela de orders, Logo Ela é Um Pedido.
Só que a Llm vai saber isso.
Bem, você pode até cometer a cagada do Fable cinco. Falar, Caraca, olha só.
Eu entendi aqui que talvez status delivered é igual.
é o que faz sentido.
Mas será que você tem Fable all over the Place? Será que você consegue.
Consumir uma vinte X em cinco minutos. Porque a Fable. Eu já vi.
Eu já vi ali me comentou que agora é igual. Fable, eu estou para conhecer. Viu.
O bichinho que gosta de comer token. Menino ali come Token. Viu.
é um ambiente sempre faminto. Então, assim o que eu estou querendo dizer é.
Como que eu sei disso?
Como que eu sei disso? Alguém pode.
Me dar uma ideia. Como que eu consigo saber disso?
Então uma coisa é: o Skl. Está correto. E não ser confiável. E quando você gera coisas que não são confiáveis, você.
Responde por elas. E aí, ó não. é seu agente que responde por elas. Tá.
Tá bom. Só para lembrar.
Responde por elas. é você. Porque o agente não pode ser accountable.
Count. Um bom. é você.
Então, olha só o valor do contexto.
Sacou, velho. Olha o valor do contexto.
Imagina se, antes de você pedir para a Helene fazer essa pesquisa, você pudesse falar o seguinte. Olha.
Eu quero que. Qual seria a característica da tabela de orders, por exemplo?
E daí? Ele vai explicar. Orders, é assim assim assado que tem uns estados assim assim assado, tal tal tal Tal Tal Ah, Tá Baseado Nisso.
Me traz aqui. Quais são todos os pedidos.
Possa ter certeza que com esse progressive disclosure que você fez com o contexto certo.
Possivelmente ele ia falar. Olha, nesse caso, a gente está considerando que os estados sejam igual. Delivered.
Logo. Essa é a quero que você vai fazer. E aí você vai ter uma cláusulaware.
Que vai literalmente fazer a diferença, ou seja.
Ninguém disse.
Sobre isso até. Até que seja dito.
Isso aqui mostra para vocês um problema que existe em todas as empresas, e que talvez você não esteja.
Alinhado ao que eu vou falar agora.
Toda empresa tem.
O Oráculo.
Toda empresa tem um oráculo cara que sabe de tudo.
Que está lá duzentos e cinquenta anos. O Matusalém, que ainda não morreu.
Que a empresa quer demitir, mas não consegue demitir esse cara, porque esse cara retém toda a informação. Enfim.
Esses caras aí estão, fadados a morrerem agora, todos eles, sem exceção.
Dá para matar todos eles hoje, tá.
Infelizmente, se for por causa disso, especificamente.
Eles morrem. Por quê?
Fonte da verdade, não é o cérebro deles. Fonte da verdade é o dado. O dado é a verdade.
Então, aonde dado está? Dentro de uma base de dados.
Basicamente, tudo que está acontecendo dentro de uma empresa hoje. Grande gente. Ela está dentro de um skrsever. Ela está Dentro De Um Pouso Ela Está Dentro De Um.
De um oro com ele. Está dentro de um Cybase. Ele está dentro de um banco de dados relacional. Possivelmente tá.
Eu diria para você assim de olho fechado noventa e cinco de todo.
O universo está dentro de uma base relacional.
Todo, sem exceção.
Há empresas.
Médias empresas, grandes até empresas, pequenas.
Isso vai perpetuar durante muitos anos.
Então, como que a gente pensa sobre isso? Tá.
Outro ponto. Um pedido, né?
Pode ser uma venda, mas será que esse pagamento foi capturado ou não? Como que eu canto esse tipo de coisa.
Isso? Regras específicas. Outro.
O que significa.
O que significa? Ontem.
Olha que idiota, né? Bem, ontem, com a Utc.
Porque se eu estiver fazendo uma query nível.
Financeiro, e eu estou utilizando o Utc, por exemplo, menos seis, um time zone diferente. O cara está consumindo isso.
No Easter. Mas eu estou mostrando Ist.
Estou utilizando Eat, por exemplo.
Eu tenho um resultado diferente.
Que não é confiado.
E outra coisa. Será que tudo chega na mesma hora? Ou eu preciso recomputacionar.
Essa informação. Então a grande questão do negócio é hoje. Você, como engenheiro de dados, não é para fazer.
Em dinheiro. Enfim, se vai fazer coisas de engenharia.
Tá. é.
E você vai lidar com o problema. E a Luana perguntou o seguinte.
Você já se deparou com esse tipo de coisa?
Toda essa história aqui que vocês vão ver é a história da minha vida. Tá.
Então, Putz, aqui a história da minha vida num ambiente extremamente real, até demais.
Real até demais. Então, todas essas lições, esses nuggets que eu estou passando. O que acontece quando você está entrando.
Com essa nova forma de abordar um problema que é impossível ser resolvido por pessoas.
Por exemplo, vocês acham que é possível você conseguir fazer a tradução de trezentos stories procedures em sete meses para Databrics.
Impossível. Cada possível tem um duzentos linhas. Tem.
Mil e setecentos linhas, dois trezentos linhas.
Você pode botar dez engenheiros. Eles não conseguem fazer cem sistemas angênicos. é um problema impossível de ser resolvido.
E que a gente resolveu em seis meses.
Então essa é a grande questão do que você constrói sistemas para poder.
Suportar toda essa carga de modificação que você vai passar.
Então a gente vai ver tudo isso.
Então, qual é a grande ideia do que a gente vai fazer ao longo desses cinco dias? A gente vai Entender O Ambiente Hoje, A Gente Vai Entender O Prompt A Gente Vai Entender O Contexto.
E a gente vai começar a pensar como a gente cria um sistema analítico para esse Cfo, para essas empresas, ou.
Plus third Party Applications que vão se conectar.
Em cima disso.
Então a gente tem um posturas.
A gente vai ter engage analítico, né? Que são permissões. A gente vai ter esse dado.
Entrando no Ductb, para que a gente possa fazer isso. E no final, a gente vai ter modelos em Dbt Para Fazer Quer Analítica E Entregar Essa Informação.
Lá dentro do sistema Analytico para eles. E a gente tem uma tabela aqui selada.
Que é a tabela de controle, né? Essa tabela de controle vai ajudar a gente para gerar erros.
No sistema, para que depois a gente possa validar.
Então a gente vai começar a entender esses processos mais dentro deles. Ali, em especificidades.
Então, o que a gente tem aqui? Basicamente, quatro tabelas. Tabela de cliente.
Trabalho de produto, tabela de pedido.
Itabela de pagamento, e aí uma das coisas muito, muito, muito importantes.
Muito importantes.
O que se relaciona com o que. O que faz o quê?
Você tem conhecimento disso, não pô? Você vai botar llm para fazer isso, vai obviamente hoje você está no mundo.
Só que a questão é a seguinte: o que é certo.
O que te garante que o que.
Cláudia retornou para você.
é certo. Como que você mensura isso.
Entende a complexidade do processo. Quando você entra num ambiente que já existe.
O que que é certo.
Poxa beleza. Se eu olhei a tabela Public Payments e eu deduzi que isso é uma tabela de captura de pagamento.
Okay, bem óbvio.
Mas talvez possa ter.
Uma tabela chamada Payments Underscore or Dlv Underscore V tres que na verdade seja.
A tabela real. Mas, na verdade, o Llm optou em.
Me trazer o public point payments, que é a tabela que não é consumida no sistema.
Por quê? Porque não passei o contexto para ele. Como que ele vai saber.
Ou seja, o que a gente está fazendo no dia a dia é guessing games.
Você está tentando botar llm: e pedir para literalmente, cara, uma caixa preta.
Tentar entender o problema. Só que a gente está lidando com.
Numéricos com informações.
Por exemplo, olha, uma dificuldade interessante aqui no rolê, né?
E obviamente que para você ser bom em alguma coisa, você precisa ter tempo. Cadeira, bunda, cadeira. Vai ter que Estudar O Sistema Vai Ter Que Entender Então.
Aonde, literalmente está.
O seu tempo hoje como engenheiro.
Em ser um furo do floor Engineer. Entender o problema, entender as características, entender o sistema.
Navegar neles, trazer o máximo de documentação possível.
Consultar a camada ontológica, se possível, literalmente, entrevistar o cliente, coletar, entender cada aspecto, cada documentação.
Trazer isso para o Llm, curar e literalmente, bater essas informações com um oráculo.
O Oráculo pode ser um ser humano. Ou pode ser um sistema.
Em que te diz o que é certo, que é errado.
Então, um exemplo. Pô, eu vou fazer uma tradução de um Sql para um Python.
Beleza. Eu vou ter um arquivo que no final falo. Olha, você vai fazer essa alteração dessa Procedidity.
No final, essa prossegura tem que retornar a dez.
Como que eu sei que isso, cara, se as duas transformações no final vão transbordar para dez. Esse é o Meu Ground Truth Essa é A Minha Verdade.
Então você precisa validar com isso. E você ainda adicionou outras características. Como por exemplo?
Dentro de uma linha. Você carrega três clocks diferentes. Olha que delícia.
Você tem ordered at.
O Updated at Ingested, Ads e Paid at.
Você tem quatro tipos, na verdade, de clocks, né?
Que são. Digitando literalmente o que é Water Act? Beleza, né? óbvio.
Então olha só, Warder at: Ele aconteceu ao Business Time.
Will Updated. Ad. é o Source Life Site. Então, quando a fonte mudou e o Ingested Ad. é quando ele chegou aqui.
Então, qual que a gente considera.
Literalmente. O que foi?
Outra coisa. Poxa dentro. Olha só. Que delícia para vocês aqui entenderem. Que delícia! Olha que delícia!
No Public Orders. Você tem um campo chamado Total Amount.
Que deu aqui como um quarenta e quatro setenta, como status de Delivered.
Mas dentro da relação da tabela, em que faz essa ligação do Order Id.
Olha só. O Payment está como cento e trinta e nove e setenta.
E é um valor diferente.
Está errado. Bem, se você não entende o contexto do problema está errado.
Cuspindo. Ia falar. Opa, está errado. Peguei o problema.
No. Está certo.
Cada coisa significa.
Uma coisa. Então não vai ter como você fugir, amigão do Prompt.
Ou não vai ter como você fugir, que está com preguiça de só aplicar e só aprender Skills e só Digitar Coisa Não Adianta Não Vai Ter Como Fugir.
No final do dia, quem vai permanecer.
é quem souber.
O problema.
Quanto mais você souber o problema.
Mais fácil vai ser sem implementar a solução ou pedir para os agentes se implementar.
Vamos abrir o sistema aqui.
E vamos ver realmente como a gente pode explorar essa informação. E como a gente pode ver.
Se esse cara está totalmente operacional, tá.
Então deixa eu trocar de telas aqui.
Eu vou mostrar para vocês a melhor ideia do mundo. Para quem não conhece a melhor ideia do mundo.
Vocês deveriam conhecer essas. Se vocês não conhecerem Xemon Yu.
A Super Engineering. Se vocês não usam.
Que deveria usar. Então hoje. Olha só.
Deixou.
Abrir aqui e já dá acesso para vocês ao repositório.
Repositório. é o nosso caso de uso transactico.
Então está aqui.
Para vocês.
Beleza.
E aí, dentro desse repositório.
Eu vou explicar o que a gente vai fazer, como a gente vai fazer e como a gente vai passar, Cada Um Deles Tá.
Vamos ativar o poder do Mega Brain. Já! Já.
Beleza. Tô gostando de ver em São nove e meia, e nós temos trezentos e onze pessoas aqui. Ainda.
Temos sobreviventes e sobreviventes, sobreviventes. Gosto disso bastante.
Da para mostrar que vocês estão extremamente interessados. Então vamos lá.
Transactico. Então todo mundo deve estar acessando agora.
E daí? A gente tem exatamente esse aí. Super engineer.
Então a gente tem aqui. Deixa, eu só recarregar.
Então a gente tem aqui o Quick Start. O que é o ambiente, a arquitetura que vocês vão poder depois Navegar Entender Deixa Eu Passar Por Elas.
Quais são os problemas que a gente pode fazer? O que a gente pode, né?
Utilizar de comando e assim por diante, tá? O que a gente vai fazer aqui? Agora.
A gente vai dentro da pasta. Live.
Get the Pasta Live tem a explicação de.
Todos os prontos e de tudo que a gente vai fazer aqui.
Então a gente na verdade vai abrir o D um.
E a gente vai começar a navegar em cada um desses caras aqui, né?
Então a grande questão do dia um é o seguinte.
Quanto de venda a transactico fez ontem.
E por que o Cfo tem que confiar nesse número?
Então, olha só. Que sério isso, beleza. Quanto que fez.
E como que eu confio nesse número, como que eu provo que esse número, que a gente vai gerar.
Ele realmente é uma evidência. E realmente ele está correto.
Isso se chama prompt contexto.
E a gente vai materializar isso lá no fim da aula.
Então a gente vai abrir aqui o primeiro, que é o setup.
E o setup. Na verdade, é só para a gente verificar se o sistema está.
Se ele está literalmente funcionando, está tudo bonitinho nele.
Então, se vocês fizerem trouxer esse ambiente para o ambiente de vocês.
O que eu quero é que vocês executem. é exatamente essa primeira parte do Prompt. Então eu vou abrir aqui.
Um terminal. E aí eu vou executar esse cara aqui.
Verificar se está tudo certo. Se o container está funcionando, se o sistema como um todo está funcionando, se a Gente Tem Dado Dentro Da Tabela.
Se as tabelas estão se comunicando. Se o Baseline está certo. Se a gente consegue fazer queries, se a gente Tem Acesso Para Isso Ou Seja.
Aqui é literalmente verificar, na perspectiva se o ambiente.
Vamos supor ali, produtiva. Ele está funcional.
Então aqui eu estou executando alguns comandos para verificar que esse cara literalmente está funcionando. Muita gente não conhece isso Porque é Uma Prática.
Eu diria muito de.
De Devopse muito também de Sis.
Que é utilizar make.
Para quem não sabe o que é make make. é uma coisa muito legal. Por quê?
Porque quando você vem aqui no make File, você tem o make file.
O que você tem no Make File? Você tem um bocado na verdade de comando, né?
E te diz o que você vai executar. Então, por exemplo, quando eu executar Setup.
Quando eu digitar make setup.
O que ele ia fazer. Ele vai fazer um teste. Vai fazer um Cp no Env. Vai fazer um Echo.
é fazer um V. Sim, que extra? Dbt.
Teve uma série de coisas ali em sequência num shell.
Isso é muito maravilhoso, tá? Por quê? Porque você começa a injetar várias coisas. Você pode ter o teste para Verificar Dp Ter Cheque Up Enfim.
Então uma dica muito legal. é tudo que você constrói.
Tenta encapsular tudo como make.
Porque você consegue fazer essas coisas que eu acho lindas dentro do repositório. Pô make help.
Mostram que você tem Make setup.
Faz o setup inteiro do ambiente para você. Make bootstrap. Inicializa esse cara.
Make Doctor, verifica se está tudo certo.
Make status. Verifica se o status está correto. Make, teste.
Roda os contratos. Make Verify.
Faz uma query make Land copia o dado. Então você vai encapsulando tudo isso em Makes.
Logo depois. Você só fala para o seu Lgm. O seguinte, cara, olha o make.
E ele vai ver o meio que vai ver exatamente quais são as coisas que ele tem disponíveis. Então isso é Uma Melhor Prática para vocês, Desenharem Ambientes.
Beleza. Outra dica legal. Outro Nugget para vocês não ficar cheio de fome hoje, né?
Outro Nugget para vocês. Então a gente executou esse Baseline, né? E a gente vai fazer um Make Doctor e O Make Status Né Para Verificar Se Tá Tudo Certo Então.
Vou ver que eu tenho tudo no Git.
E aqui a gente vai fazer um Mc Docoxing, um Mix Stars. Então, literalmente, a gente tem as quatro tabelas. Olha só.
Temos cinco mil. Customers.
Quatrocentos products, sessenta e dois mil Orders e sessenta mil Payments. Tá.
Beleza. Então, aqui a gente tem esse ambiente comum. Todo.
Beleza. Tudo certo. Até aí.
O que que a gente vai fazer agora. E a gente vai.
Primeiro, né?
Que a week prompt. Olha que delícia. Isso aqui. Eu vejo muita gente fazendo, inclusive, né?
Eu hoje lidero uma.
Vamos chamar do que gente. Tribo Whatever. Eu lidero uma tribo hoje com três engenheiros de Ya ou assim por diante.
E aí eles fazem isso. Aqui, por exemplo, eles vão entrar dentro do repositório e falam: galera, entra dentro do repositório.
E aí? Faz isso.
Eu estou botando em português para ficar mais simples, tá? Para vocês receberem em português para justificar aqui.
Analisa esse banco de dados e explique a receita. Responda em português do Brasil usando o máximo de seis bullets. Um palavras, tá.
Se considera essa parte aqui. Mas muita gente vai meter um prompt. Ele mete o Prompt de jeito.
Verifica os dados de receita e explica a receita.
Beleza. Olha só o que ele vai fazer.
Vou inspecionar o Warehouse. Duck, Db: E o Postwls para entender o modelo de receita.
Só que tem um problema. Isso aqui é extremamente amplo.
Então, quando eu peço para ele analisar um banco de dados e explicar a receita.
Veja que eu tenho um esqueleto só de Dbt. Eu não tenho nada escrito.
Mas mesmo assim, o que ele está tentando fazer é buscar informação de post goes indeed errado. Ele deveria ir Na Fonte De Dados Mas A Culpa Não é Dele.
é do animal de teta que simplesmente deu um prompt completamente fraco.
Para que ele possa literalmente atuar. O problema é.
Quanto menos você sabe.
Menos te ajuda. Então, geralmente.
Essa parte da Llm passa a ser tipo.
Proporcionar o seu conhecimento.
Cara, se você sabe muito bem.
Você tem resultados assim?
Exorbitantes. Se você.
Não sabe o que você está perguntando.
Você deixa vários furos abertos. Esses furos vão te cobrar muito caros.
Principalmente porque. Olha só.
Ele teve alguns Assumptions aqui, então, olha só. Analisei Warehouse.
A cópia do Post, mas a receita não é um número. Só depende de qual evento você reconhece.
Então, por exemplo.
Está vendo isso aqui? Eu vou abrir o Woo my Pie.
E aqui. Eu vou selecionar o Deep Sick pro.
Depois eu vou abrir aqui o Groc.
E depois eu vou abrir o Codex. O sol.
Eu vou fazer a mesma pergunta para os quatro. Então eu fiz a pergunta para o Opus.
Então tive, basicamente ele falando: quais são as tabelas.
A regra de valor que ele entendeu que é o total. Mal chegou a quantity.
Plus linux price menos desconto.
Depois ele falou que o pedido de pagamento são um para um quando existe pagamento.
Depois ele falou que a receita capturada foi de oitenta e seis milhões e blá, blá, blá. Com o processo de starus captured.
E a receita bruta de pedidos não cancelados foi noventa e dois milhões. A diferença de quatro novecentos. Valor devolvido a estornado.
Por isso os dois números discordam.
Ontem setecentos e cinquenta pedidos, somando.
Um milhão, tal mais tal total? Capturamos no mesmo dia.
A defasagem vem do pedido. Detectar. Nenhum defeito injetado está presente na Corp desse dado beleza.
Agora, olha só. Que interessante. No final do dia, se a gente for analisar, por exemplo.
O My pai. E aqui eu utilizei o Dipsic V quatro Pro, por exemplo, para poder fazer isso, né?
Vamos ver como ele vai se comportar em relação a isso.
Pô qual o resultado que ele vai me retornar?
Aqui. Olha só o Groc.
Já falou. Não existe receita no esquina.
Olha que anta. Mas não é ele que é anta. A gente só não deu contexto para ele.
Então, basicamente, ele não conseguiu me retornar. Nada interessante, porque o Pront foi extremamente.
Inconclusivo, extremamente aberto.
Está vendo? Então ele não conseguiu absolutamente nada. Nada, nada, nada. Zero.
Ele só falou dos cantos. Não tornou nenhum resultado.
Tá.
Beleza.
Aí vamos. Aqui no nosso maravilhoso.
Gpt. Cinco, seis. Só.
O grock é anta. Sim.
Cara. O Grock é muito bom assim eu uso muito o Grock para.
Ler documentação, explicar code base. Ele é muito rápido.
Para ele destilar informação rápida. Ele é muito bom.
Mas quando a gente está trabalhando em nuances mais financeiras, enfim, ele funciona muito bem.
Mas você precisa ter um pronto muito, muito interessante para o que ele faz.
Então, daí você começa a entender um pouquinho o que cada modelo faz. Muito bem.
Por exemplo. Olha só. Olha o que o Grok. O que o Dix fez.
O de psique já te retornou alguma coisa bem mais interessante aqui.
Receita bruta de noventa e cinco milhões.
Eletrônicos representam. Enfim, eu não perguntei nada sobre isso, mas beleza. Canal Web domina Brasil. Concentra beleza, crescimento mensal acelerado.
Então, assim analise esse banco de dados e explique a receita. Então, cara, isso pode ter diversos.
Aberturas aqui.
No final das contas, eu não tive o resultado que eu espero que eu deseje.
O teu desejo. Então, o seguinte. A questão é: a gente compilou a intenção.
Correta. ó, já o.
Já o chat Gpt, o sol.
Ele já foi mais inteligente.
Mas veja que as informações divergem.
Então.
Que eu quero deixar claro aqui para vocês é que.
Um prompt ruim gera um resultado ruim.
Independente.
Do an email que você está usando. Posso botar o Fable lá.
Ele vai retornar a uma coisa mais bonitinha ali.
Mas será que aquilo realmente está correto.
E o que a gente vai descobrir, por exemplo, ali é cara.
Qual Database que ele escolheu.
Quem definiu que é venda.
Qual foi a evidência que foi reproduzida.
O que ele considerou que ele não considerou.
Então, literalmente, é se você tem um prompt que não é bem estruturado, você está literalmente deixando.
A que desejar. Beleza.
Então o Prompt ao contrato. Ele é a base de tudo. E aí? é por isso que vem aqui. A Ideia De Você Não Prompt Mais Porque Senão Acontece Esse Tipo De Coisa.
Então você pronto. Tem o sistema para o sistema Prom optar os agentes a fazerem o que ele quer.
Então você tem que um pilar, literalmente a intenção.
Porque literalmente, o Gap aqui é o entendimento do que você quer.
é literalmente entender o que você quer passar para.
Então, por exemplo.
Qual foi o banco de dados que ele escolhe?
O que ele definiu como venda.
O que ele produziu exatamente? Teve alguma evidência que ele produziu para confirmar aquilo? Isso é um início, por exemplo, de.
Uma ideia de cara qual igual que eu preciso habilitar para garantir que aquela receita sempre.
Vai ter a informação correta.
Qual é a core que eu tenho que construir para isso?
Depois. Qual foi a minha cláusula, né?
Em que eu pudesse parar. Ou seja, olha.
O que significa, por exemplo.
Veja quanto de receita. E aí o sistema retorna para você. Tá, amigão?
O que é receita? Me esclarece o que é receita no seu contexto. Aí, Brother.
Que é assim aqui pode significar várias coisas. Você está querendo dizer que receita é.
O preço, mais o desconto. Vezes o preço unitário é. Ah, não, não é.
Então define para mim o que a gente está tentando fazer? Compilar a intenção. A gente está literalmente tentar entender Quais São As Características Do Sistema.
Que foi exatamente o que a gente falou. A fluência não é evidência.
O Prompt dá ao agente uma estrutura ou nenhuma estrutura para ele acreditar. Então vai depender de como você escreve isso.
A ideia é que a gente não escreva mais esse tipo de coisa.
Porque o Prompt é um contrato.
Do que você vai literalmente estabelecer.
Como que a gente constrói um bom contrato, constrói um bom prompt cara.
Um bom prompt. Ele tem que ter um objetivo.
Ele tem que ter. O que você espera. Ele tem que ter um escopo.
Ele tem que ter explusões, se necessário. Ele tem que ter.
Ferramentas permitidas. Ele tem que ter evidências. Ele tem que ter artefatos. Ele tem que ter características em que você.
Para o que você se coloque no loop. Então eles precisam ser literalmente bem descritos, né?
Então por um objetivo, né?
Um assignment específico, um outcome para você ter uma resposta. Um escopo, pô que não seja o Duck. Db: Porque A Gente Quer Buscar Essa Informação Do.
Eles têm tem um sistema ainda. A exclusão.
Ou seja, para que você precisa.
Escrever isso toda hora.
Não, você não precisa escrever isso toda hora. Agora é muito importante você entender a anatomia de um prompt.
Entender como ele faz entender o que é um chain of thoughts. Entender todos os básicos de prompting.
Mas a ideia é que você faça coisas mais avançadas do que isso, que a gente vai ver aqui.
Então, por exemplo, como que a gente melhora aquilo ali? Olha só. Que interessante.
Vamos lá. No nosso dois.
E agora a gente vai criar uma nova sessão.
E o que a gente vai fazer? A gente vai literalmente entender qual é o problema.
A gente vai investigar esse contrato.
E a gente vai fazer uma coisa muito legal. A gente vai ter um retail.
Human in the loop para confirmar se aquilo faz sentido.
Então, olha só. Que irado isso aqui.
A gente vai mudar a característica.
A gente vai criar.
Novo. E aí, aqui eu vou utilizar o Fable, porque eu estou muito corajoso de explorar minha assinatura.
E aí eu vou colocar o seguinte.
Ainda não. Investigue.
Para a pergunta: qual foi a receita? Transact ficou ontem. Por que o Ceo deveria confiar nesse número? Proponha um contrato compacto.
Use uma única tabela.
Com, no mínimo, oito linhas.
O objetivo. Resultado: escopo exclusões, autoridade, ferramenta, evidência, artefatos.
Considere o posto preço público como fonte primária. Somente leitores. Clouductb, Dbt Analytics.
Control Injection e assim por diante. Eu já estourei aqui.
Contra um injection superfície, assim por diante. Usa o mínimo de trezentos palavras. Então, olha só.
Um trato proposto. Então ele está propondo uma estrutura do que acredita que ele seja interessante de você passar para ele. Olha só.
Objetivo. Calcular a receita de Transact de ontem.
Hoje é dia nove. Hoje é dia dez. Ontem, dia nove.
Resultado. Valor único de receita em moeda, escopo, somente leitura no postgress, exclusão Dark Tv, autoridade, ferramenta, evidência.
Artefato e condição pô, parece muito mais estruturado e muito mais interessante, literalmente, do que.
O que a gente viu anteriormente. Dito isso.
Agora eu estou no loop.
Então, confia nesse contrato? Confirmo contrato confirmado com quatro esclarecimentos ontem. é inicialmente o último dia calendário Utc.
Completa apenas como janela. Técnica.
Na primeira bifurcação sobre receita. Registre candidatos físicos. Não escolha nenhum.
E escalha. O responsável financeiro.
Cada checkpoint autoriza explicitamente seus próprios artefatos.
Nenhuma amplificação. Desculpa, é permitido sem confirmação humana. Responda com um checklist de no máximo, seis linhas.
Confirmando o entendimento. Não use ferramentas. Não escreva arquivos.
E pare.
Gente. Qual é a grande sacada aqui? Pô, eu preciso entender isso.
Sabe como que você vai entender isso? Se você entender um sistema.
Se você aprender a compilar intenções, se você literalmente entendeu que você está perguntando.
Então era só entendido e confirmado. Janela.
Nenhum artefato gerado. Escopo parado. Aguardando autorização para o primeiro passo de investigação.
Então, quando a gente fala em contrato.
O que a gente quer fazer. A gente quer garantir informações que são extremamente precisas e importantes.
Na prática.
Isso acontece por debaixo dos panos.
Se você tem um sistema de looping, por exemplo, em que você fala, cara, essa é a intenção. Eu quero Fazer Isso Eu Quero Descobrir Assim Assim Assado O Objetivo é Esse E Esse Tal.
Eu literalmente cria uma boa estrutura.
Da intenção. O sistema vai receber aquele Prompt e ele vai chamar sub agentes para consultar essa informação.
E aí esses subagentes na verdade, vão receber de um orquestrador.
Que essa é a grande. O grande nome que eu, Orchestrator Worker. Ele vai receber.
As características do que ele ia fazer. Você é um cara financeiro que está fazendo isso, e isso. Seu objetivo é Fazer Tal Tal Tal Coisa.
Você vai fazer uma query baseada nisso. Nisso.
Ele vai te trazer exatamente o contexto do prompt que você aprendeu.
E daí isso começa a me dar uma ideia interessante do seguinte.
Será que isso é repetitivo?
Me respondi: será que perguntar um sistema constante vezes e tentar interrogar e tentar entender.
E realmente trabalhar. Esse processo me responde no chat.
Ele é algo repetitivo e canônico. Quando eu falo canônico.
é algo que pode servir para qualquer coisa.
Ou seja, se eu estou entrevistando um sistema, se eu quero entender sobre o sistema, será que não poderia ter Um Processo De Entrevista.
Ao sistema. Será que eu poderia fazer isso?
Sim ou não? O Walker também é muito.
Pode falar ládio.
Meu pessoal. Boa noite, Luan. Obrigado por mais uma aí.
Boa noite. Estamos.
Sempre bom estar ouvindo você.
Seguinte: o que eu comentei antes lá do Rfc para a gente pegar os requisitos funcionais e os requisitos não funcionais. Você acha que, por exemplo, você Falou com o Cfo lá, né? Aí eu Até Perguntei Pô O Que eu Precisava Falar com O Cfo Aí Você Falou Que Todo.
Tudo está ali, já dentro do sistema. Como query? Como procedures e tudo mais.
O interessante seria mapear o que tem mapeado. Entrega para o Cfo ou.
Para quem seja de negócio lá, ou já abre. Sei lá. é o que eu comentei, né? Da Rf.
Já para pegar esses requisitos funcionais.
Justamente que você falou também. Ah, o Oráculo lá. O cara que tem ele.
Se ele for mandado embora, beleza, a gente vai ter que fazer isso porque muita gente não sabe como.
Funciona. Qual que é a abordagem que seria interessante fazer.
Boa pergunta. é complexa, porque vai depender do ambiente que você está. Mas no final do dia, você tem que Ter Alguma Prova Irrefutável Do Valor Que Você Tem.
Que você tem ali gerado pela Llm.
A questão pode literalmente alucinar, que não é por causa.
Que ela é burra, mas porque ela não entende os contextos. Então.
O que seria a grande questão.
é ter uma base em que a Llm possa ter confiança de consultar. A questão é: como a gente constrói essa base, sacou.
Então, assim, Rfc, contexto de gira documentação. Tudo isso é importante, mas ainda tem um problema. Como o João falou ali.
Eu preciso de alguém para falar, o que é certo e o que é errado.
Então, por exemplo.
Eu preciso de, por exemplo, uma pessoa para me dizer o que é certo e o que é errado.
Bem no início, possivelmente você precisa de uma pessoa te dando o que é certo e que errado.
Ou não, ou não. às vezes você não precis.
Quer ver uma prova disso? Por exemplo?
Se você tem um sistema Fontend que gera um relatório no Power Bi de dois quinhentos e quarenta e sete.
Que está lá funcionando há dois anos e que o Cfo baseia todas as análises dele. Bate esses números lá.
Já é uma informação confiável para eles.
Ele já entende que aquela informação confiável para ele, porque ele já validou aquela informação.
Ele já literalmente entende aquela intimação. Ele já foi atrás dessa informação.
Que esse é o dashboard que ele usa realmente para reportar lá para o Ceo. As inflações financeiras. Há dois anos.
Você precisa de alguém para fazer isso.
Bem, se você tem acesso ao sistema, se você consegue tirar eles para isso.
Você pode fazer toda a engenharia reversa e descobrir de onde aquele número vem. Para onde ele vai.
Obviamente que vai te requerer muito mais engenharia, que vai ser muito mais complexo, mas dá para fazer.
Então, muitas das vezes você precisa do humano.
Muitas das vezes você não precisa, mas.
A melhor forma de você extrair isso.
é de um ano. é mais rápido, porque.
Cara. Se a gente for entrar numa empresa hoje.
Cara, o que é o tanto de documentação que existe.
O que é certo e o que é errado.
Alguém tem que validar esse tipo de coisa. Então por isso que eu falo que a engenharia de contexto.
Cara. Quem dominar a engenharia de contexto.
Vai estar muito bem, porque a engenharia de contexto é um insumo para tudo isso.
Então, literalmente, eu acredito que um dos focos de qualquer engenheiro.
é focar em contexto.
Muito, muito importante, muito pertinente. E eu vou abrir aqui. O que eu acredito que seja uma coisa legal de contexto.
E obviamente que eu vou explicar pedaços.
De contexto. A gente pode entrar e ficar.
Caras. Posso ter um workshop? Podes ter um budista de quinze horas só sobre o contexto. Ainda não vai ser O Suficiente Porque Existem Várias Nuances.
Qual é a grande sacada.
Volto a dizer que.
Gosto muito do que o Rafa falou. Cara, começa, pequeno.
E veja qual o problema que você quer atacar. E aí você vai evoluindo.
Ah, pô. Eu quero criar um reggae beleza. Você precisa do reggae. Então você vai literalmente se grilar, vai se Perguntar Pô é Realmente Eu Entendi Que Eu Preciso De Um Rag Ok.
O reggae vai resolver esse meu problema aqui. Beleza.
Qual o tipo de reggae aí. Galera, fala, pô.
Vou já fazer um agente Crag, né.
Cara. Extremamente complexo, extremamente caro.
Para um tipo de problema que, na verdade.
The Feeds faz um defeat um pouquinho do reggae, na minha opinião, como um todo.
Que você está em várias camadas do Graph, pedindo para que ele faça vários reasoning.
Em cima do contexto. Então isso causa alucinação.
Então pô. Começa com o reggae simples.
Começa com armazenar e recuperar. Muito bem. Quebrar os vetores em Chunks. Enfim.
Valida isso com a equipe. Valida isso com o Ceo valida com quem sabe da informação. Sempre haverá alguém que sabe daquela informação.
Mostra o valor em cima disso. E vai crescendo ao longo do processo.
Então eu realmente entendo.
Construindo contexto.
Que é a grande chave do contexto.
é literalmente como o que você estabelece.
E o que você escolhe criar. Existem várias formas de você prover contexto hoje. Que eu vou explicar um pouquinho.
Então, principalmente cara.
Objetivo que eu quero dar.
Qual escopo que é preciso.
Qual é o tipo de autoridade que eu tenho.
Qual a evidência quando é necessário e quando não.
Como que eu respondo essas perguntas, né?
Então o Prompt. Ele te leva ao entendimento. Talvez da clarificação.
Mas a certeza isso acontece dentro do contexto.
E aí, o que é interessante, né?
Muita gente acredita que muita gente. Mas eu sei que muita gente aqui já entende que não.
Quanto maior a sua janela.
Melhor, na verdade.
Não, nem sempre.
às vezes tem uma janela muito grande. Te atrapalha em muita coisa. A janela é algo que passa.
Mas literalmente certas perguntas que você faz. Que precisam dos Tanks ou das informações do meio.
Se fazem perdidas. A gente tem aquele problema da Llm do Loss in the Mirror. Atenção, funciona muito bem no início.
Funcionam muito bem no final, mas não funcionam muito bem no meio.
Então, como que a gente lida com isso? Então a gente tem vários tipos de validações de Long e volta. Poder Garantir Realmente Que A Gente, Ter Uma Curácia De Recuperação.
Daí vai a importância.
Da memória. Só que aí.
A gente começa a pensar o seguinte: Pô beleza.
Eu contexto.
E aí? Olha só. Tem várias formas de prover contexto.
Você pode copiar e colar.
Você pode utilizar um agente Search que é literalmente você vai pedir para o agente ir lá e fazer uma pesquisa.
Você pode literalmente pedir para fazer um reggae.
Que é literalmente numa base.
Major Heat Or Argument Generation, argumentada e literalmente, recuperar uma informação que está dentro de uma base sendo alimentada.
Você pode ter um Graph Reg que vai analisar relações.
Entre nós. E Edson vai falar. Pô, existe uma relação.
Que tem? Acho que está piscando aqui também. Deixa eu ver se teve algum lag aqui.
Existe uma relação, por exemplo, de.
Payments. Mm.
Orders, beleza. Qual é essa relação? Então elas são dois nós, né?
Você tem os Eds que se conectam com ela.
Por exemplo, está fazendo um flickering aqui. Depois eu vejo o que é. Tá.
Memória. Aí. Aqui já vem uma outra complexidade. Pô beleza. Eu tenho.
O contexto. Mas e a memória?
é uma memória de.
Duração de longa duração.
Semântica episódica.
The Depende. Como você vai escolher. Por que você escolhe outro ponto? Você tem um século de Brain, por exemplo.
Você tem informações armazenadas.
Dentro de um repositório que pode servir para você. Adicionalmente, trabalhar com essa informação.
Outra. Você tem uma camada ontológica de dados.
Muita gente não conhece isso, cara. Disse que vai explodir no mercado. Tanto é que se a gente olhar lá.
Geneontology, eu acho, né.
Eu acho que é isso. O nome.
Se eu não me engano.
Gineontology.
Então a ideia é ter uma camada que entende, né?
Ou seja, o que ele faz aqui, né? Ele extrai todas as informações, as diferentes fontes ali.
E coloca isso de uma forma com que os agentes possam entender.
Então nada mais é do que pegar todas essas informações aqui.
Colocar dentro de uma camada que qualquer agente possa identificar essa informação e ter um entendimento muito melhor do que Você Pediu Para A Gente Direto Na Base.
Vou provar isso para vocês agora, tá.
Aí. Você também tem via em Cp. Você tem vias, Skills, e assim por diante. Tá.
Então você pode fazer um bocado de coisas em relação a isso.
Luan. Você pretende criar algum conteúdo mais focado no ecossistema do Databrics? Com certeza.
A gente vai ter isso daqui duas semanas.
Vou lançar. Na verdade, eu estou terminando o workshop. Que vai ser sobre. Sobre.
Data, Brics. Me lembro no final, que eu mostro para vocês.
Outro ponto muito importante. Uma coisa dentro do contexto é você ingerir outra coisa é você recuperar.
Então, pô. A gente chama isso de recall.
E a gente mede essa taxa de recall com a qualidade disso. Uma das formas de medir isso é como.
Formando sobras de medir. Isso é literalmente você ter o quê?
Você ter telimetria.
Para poder fazer isso, né?
E aí, quando a gente olha.
Aqui, nos contextos.
Deixa eu consertar esse Flickering aqui.
Quando você olha esses contextos, do que a gente está vendo. Na verdade, é o seguinte.
é pô o que eu consigo entregar. Que está vinculado ao sistema.
Tá? Deixa eu só passar aqui um review.
Então, por exemplo, negócio.
Quando eu preciso responder uma informação do que é alguma coisa. Pô, isso é uma informação interessante. Você ter no Second Brain.
Que você vai aprender, por exemplo, a criar isso vai entender as mecânicas disso.
O que realmente.
Eu tenho.
Eu preciso entender termos.
O que significa o Revenue? O que é um status de ativo? Enfim.
Aqui. Você tem ontologia.
Se eu quero fazer perguntas no sistema, eu preciso de um cloud Md de um Agents. Eu preciso de uma estrutura de memória.
Eu diria.
De qual o nome que eu quero usar de rotas para que eu possa buscar essa informação.
So, data operacional. Eu quero buscar informação operacional. Tenho acesso a fazer isso. Via Mcp, por exemplo.
Evidência. Pô, eu preciso achar uma evidência em memória.
Então, o que acontece.
O que você precisa entender só para vocês.
Situarem no final do dia.
O que vocês precisam entender que é o seguinte.
Para cada tipo de problema que você quer resolver, você precisa.
De um tipo de solução.
E eu costumo dizer que você não resolve problemas modernos com tecnologias ou conceitos ultrapassados.
Que são antigos. Você resolve de formas.
Novos, por exemplo, teve alguma coisa legal?
O contexto tem que ser selecionado, não descarregado. Isso é um problema muito grande, cara.
Porque de novo, não é só construir o contexto.
Garantir que o seu contexto funciona muito bem.
Recall funciona muito bem.
Well Retrieval como um todo. Tanta parte de escrever quanto a parte de recuperar a função. Muito bem.
Então não é só ter apoio. Tem um contexto gigantesco. Mas quanto mais informação, quanto mais informações o alimento para o Agente.
Ou por multiagente, mas perigoso. Ele é de.
Tomar assumptions. Por isso, a ideia de você ter uma tarefa atômica.
Uma tarefa atômica te mostra exatamente, cara. é isso que eu quero que você faça para essa tarefa com essa validação. Dessa forma.
Nessas características. Então você começa a destilar. Está vendo que a gente está conectando toda a história até aqui?
Justamente por causa disso.
Então vamos dar uma olhadinha. Como que a gente evolui agora.
No contexto, né.
Então a gente viu prompts.
A gente viu o contrato.
Mas agora, o que que a gente quer ver aqui? A gente quer ver como criar contexto.
E tudo que a gente está vendo aqui, a gente está vendo na mão, mas eventualmente, no final do dia dessa sessão hoje. Você, Vê cara, Como Que Eu Automatizo isso por quê Porque agora Eu Entendi.
A importância do Prompt, a importância de entender o negócio e, literalmente, como que eu crio contexto em relação a isso.
Então, uma nova sessão. A gente vai fazer uma investigação aqui. Interessante, tá? Então eu vou.
Basicamente falar o seguinte.
Leia o conteúdo do inventário.
E executa somente a parte. Capture contract tá.
Tratem esse arquivo apenas como instrução, não com evidência. Comércio do zero.
Os máximo de Ids na reconciliação. E o que que a gente vai fazer? A gente na verdade, vai fazer.
Uma navegada.
Em cima do contrato, para entender o seguinte.
As evidências que nós temos. ó evidências do Rid me.
Evidências do zero um esquema Sql, Cid Pi, posto Spi. Está vendo que a gente está sendo bem mais enfático? Quais São As Evidências Para Eu Entender Qual O Valor Que Eu Tenho Que Reportar Para O Ceo.
Exclui para mim ontologia nesse momento, que eu vou mostrar para vocês. Agora vocês vão gostar.
Qual é o Tc completa depois, qual o mínimo de provas que eu tenho que ter para poder para ter uma informação realmente.
Então ele vai na verdade utilizar esse prompt.
Para ler esse conteúdo aqui.
E tentar navegar dentro da estrutura que a gente tem.
Para poder trazer esse resultado.
Então eu vou abrir um novo Prompt aqui.
Deixa eu voltar aqui como super engineering, vou abrir um novo prompt. Aqui.
Vou literalmente pedir para que ele escreva essa informação, tá? E o resultado? Outro ponto importante. Tá.
No final do dia. Eu quero que ele escreva essas informações dentro de um arquivo.
Então a gente trabalha muito com llms ou com sistemas multiharness, por exemplo, fazendo isso.
Então, por exemplo, pode fazer pesquisa.
Grava num repositório. Por exemplo, a gente vai com um contexto limpo. Sobe, por exemplo, Codex, e aí faz algum Outro Tipo De Coisa.
Escreve esse cara e dali a pouco eu pego, por exemplo, o Kimi, e utilizo isso e crio o processo como um todo.
No final do dia, o que seria transformar tudo isso numa coisa só interessante.
é você poder ter uma coisa assim? Mais ou menos.
Deixa eu ver se eu consigo achar aqui.
Aqui. ó tal tal tal tal aqui, ó uma tarefa, por exemplo.
No final do dia, quem estiver online lá na quarta feira vai entender exatamente isso aqui, que eu vou explicar Ao Longo Dos Dias.
Mas a gente vai ter uma tarefa. Isso aqui é uma tarefa.
Tarefa que se chama T dois mil e vinte e seis oitenta e três.
Foundation Single Review, Entry Point Challenged, Md.
Então, o que é essa tarefa?
Porque essa tarefa.
Com o objetivo dessa tarefa.
Qual o contexto dessa tarefa?
Qual o comportamento que eu espero dessa tarefa.
Qual é o critério de sucesso aí? Aqui o negócio fica doido. Tá vendo? Use voz.
Então, qual igual que ele tem que fazer.
Ele tem que rodar o rebuild ponto Sh. E tem que dar um eco de não fazer rebuilding.
Ele tem que fazer um grap lá no Rebuild, buscar. Exatamente que aquele artefato funcionou.
Ele tem que fazer um Crow ali, fazer um Installation para verificar que funcionou.
No Ival dois. Ele tem que executar uma série de coisas. Tá vendo, Ival três.
Ou seja, o que é isso aqui é literalmente uma validação. Do que eu espero, daquela atividade atômica de execução.
Então, o que eu quero aqui.
Eu quero literalmente estabelecer um comando de Rebuild, por exemplo.
Vamos ver se eu tenho uma aqui de Dbt.
Aqui! ó, que legal!
Model source. Então o que eu tenho que conseguir fazer nesse vol? Eu tenho que conseguir fazer um porte lá.
Um código literalmente, que vai retornar um resultado.
Se esse resultado desse valo não for positivo, o que ele vai fazer.
Ele vai ficar preso no Exitcheck.
Então ele tem dentro de uma tarefa. Um loop, cara. Ele vai lopar em cima do Exitcheck.
Ele vai ter um Rollback Plan. Se isso. Aquilo não vai funcionar. Ele tem várias informações aqui. Ou seja, é Uma Atividade é Uma Tarefa Atômica.
Que dentro dela tem todas as instruções.
Tem um objetivo. Tem um contexto.
Tem o Behavior. Ou seja, tem o Prd do requisito. Tem tudo.
Então vocês vão ter acesso a esse cara que é chamado de test Spec aqui, e vocês vão conseguir gerar isso.
Por um processo. Cara, eu tenho essa atividade. Geram até esse aspecto para mim. Ela vai gerar para você.
E depois você vai chamar qualquer agente, o sub agente pedir para executar aquela atividade por ti.
Então aqui, ele começou a ler essas informações, e vai escrever esse cara dentro daquele arquivo que a gente falou de história.
Então ó.
Arquivo gravado com sucesso.
Contexto. Então, olha só aqui.
Então ele buscou algumas informações aqui do contexto. Ele fez.
As informações que a gente pediu e fez uma conta ali.
Showed, cem, dezassete e um pedidos. Então aqui a gente está vendo que.
Evidências.
Estamos vendo evidências. Tá.
Então já deu uns Mind Blowings aí, né? Galera?
Isso que a gente está no dia um, tá? A gente.
Survivably bastante. Esse sistema vai automatizar ele. A gente vai começar com pouca automação.
E a gente vai navegar.
Até a automação completa do loop.
Não só para vocês entenderem aqui. Por isso que é importante você entender cada pedaço. Ah, eu já sei.
Tá básico demais. Não fica comigo aqui. Que a gente vai construindo todo esse processo.
Então aqui o que eu estou tentando? O que eu estou querendo mostrar para vocês.
Que eu estou querendo mostrar para vocês.
Que a gente está construindo contexto.
Compensaristas. Então, olha só. Que legal!
Primeiro pedido. Pô, eu fiz lá uma soma.
Segundo pedido, fiz uma soma. Só que agora não no pedido. No Payments.
Capturei diferentes pontos. Tem um gap de valor. E aqui ele explica o Rashonnell aqui. Ele explica qual é a conta.
Aquele explica os requisitos. Me fala dos inventários. Do que ele achou. Me fala das evidências. Eu estou fazendo o Que A Gente Chama De Progressive Disclosure.
Eu estou pedindo fragmentos enquanto a gente vai para coletar essas informações.
You Were a Link vai funcionar muito bem nisso.
Pedindo um Clean Ledger, ou seja, uma história, literalmente. Do que é.
Pedir o Sql. Exato. Do que significa cada uma dessas informações. Olha só. Que foda.
Que ele retornou cada evidência que ele fez. Ou seja, aqui. Eu tenho informações para literalmente chegar ali, por exemplo, Para O Meu Oráculo.
Que agora é a parte do foda.
A gente falou que o Oráculo precisa ser humano, né?
Então, calma aí. Deixa eu dar uma voadora aqui na cabeça de vocês, rapidão só de leve.
Para vocês entender como matar pessoas. Em três, dois, um.
Um pouquinho mais diferente desse mais.
Vocês seguiram a ideia, né? Então, beleza. Então, o que a gente fez aqui nesse prompt? Tres, né? A gente capturou.
Viu as evidências entender um pouquinho. E agora a gente vai fazer uma coisa muito foda.
Que se chama ontologia.
Separar o dado do significado.
A gente já vai.
Nela. Rapidinho.
Agora pensa comigo o seguinte.
Será que tudo isso que a gente está fazendo pode ser automatizado. Imagina a loucura.
E a gente está falando isso no dia um, né? Imagina se.
Você conseguisse ter.
Um processo canônico.
Em que tanto Greenfield ou Brownfield você conseguisse trabalhar.
O processo inteiro.
Ou seja, conseguir se entender.
Questionar, refutar, coletar evidência.
Entender quais são as tarefas. Decompor atividade, validar essa atividade.
Quebrar em vários pedaços.
Criar uma unidade atômica de trabalho, chamar um lop para construir.
Coletar feedback, mover entre partes e começar tudo de novo.
Será que esse processo que a gente está fazendo aqui? Vai levar a gente a criar uma Dark Factory.
é exatamente isso. A gente está entendendo? Os componentes principais.
A conseguir uma fábrica que pode ser para qualquer coisa.
Beleza.
E a gente vai entender, ao longo dessas aulas que a gente vai construir. Skills.
Uma das partes é construir esquilos para fazer isso.
Para que você não precise repetir essa informação. Esse processo de novo.
Mas a grande questão é, como que eu sei que eu preciso de uma Skill se eu não entendo qual O Problema Que Eu Estou Resolvendo.
Mas eu sei, por exemplo, que questionar fontes e entender sobre elas.
é um exercício constante que a gente faz por elenes.
Então, o que é o contexto?
Faz com que um resultado possa mudar.
Em vez de ser dez milhões, seja realmente sete, oito milhões.
E é aí que vem a parte de como você cria todo esse movimento.
Da medida do valor.
Do que é significado.
E do que literalmente, o humano decide.
E isso acontece somente se você tiver uma coisa chamada Ontologia.
Então isso aqui é muito foda. Antes de eu passar aqui.
Quem aqui não conhece sobre odontologia fala eu. Porque a ideia é vocês não conhecerem mesmo vocês explodirem a mente aqui.
Temos duzentos e setenta e dois vivos. Ainda.
Nossa. Então aqui vai ser o ponto arrábado da noite. Viu, galera?
Aqui amanhã.
Como que eu implemento ontologia.
Aqui é a parte que vocês vão ficar.
Doidos, tá.
Então, olha só. O Luan falou no começo.
E não necessariamente. Seria de um humano.
Obviamente que é muito importante, mas como que a gente provém inteligência com a gente.
Bem, a gente consegue garantir. Vamos lá. Pergunta para vocês. E aí sejam.
Muito sinceros. Aqui. A gente consegue garantir.
Independentemente do Llm. Tá.
E que vai pesquisar uma base.
Quando eu falar para aquele animal de teta.
Veja quais foram os últimos pedidos.
Ele sempre vai acertar a tabela.
Sim ou não?
Não, né? Mas a gente ainda faz isso.
Então, qual é a grande questão?
Olha só. Que loucura. A ontologia preserva o significado enquanto o sistema muda.
Olha que louco!
Então, olha só o significado. Não é o tipo de dado.
E não a imigração que ele carrega. A ontologia é o artefato.
Que mostra ou, literalmente reforça.
O significado fora das engines, cara. Olha que loucura.
Entidade, relacionamento.
Regra evento.
Previsão. Quem é? Don.
Quem escreveu isso é literalmente canônico.
Isso pode ser totalmente.
Reproduzir.
Imagina se você conseguisse ter um sistema de ontologia canônico que pudesse fazer algo assim. Por exemplo.
Imagine que você tivesse um post. Chris.
E daí você tivesse um sistema que se conectasse nesse Postwess.
Lesse todas as suas tabelas.
Todas as suas colunas, todos os tipos.
Todos os status, entender isso absolutamente. Todas essas informações.
Mandasse isso para uma camada onde ele vai criar o conceito de entidade.
Vai criar o conceito de relacionamento.
Vai criar o conceito de regras e eventos.
Vai criar o conceito do que é certo e do que é errado.
Daí ele vai validar essas informações.
Ele vai criar termo.
Glossário, status, questões que ele não entendeu.
Regras em que não estão claras.
E que você possa, depois de todo esse processo de extração, declaração.
Enriquecimento. Você consegui ter uma que pesquise sobre isso. Ele possa entender o significado das coisas. Em vez de tentar adivinhar.
Quando ele faz literalmente uma query direta no sistema em que você não sabe o que ele vai responder.
Então, exatamente uma ontologia poderia estar disponível via Mcp. Então imagina que foda isso aqui. Olha só, Sol Visbunde. Para vocês.
E que ficar online vai ter acesso a esses conteúdos.
Sumarizados, né? No final. Então, olha só.
Imagine que você tem o seguinte.
Você tem um.
A skate.
Você tem o mundo. Você tem uma Api.
Cara. Eu estou ensinando para vocês o futuro de qualquer empresa, tá.
Só isso.
Só isso que eu estou mostrando para vocês aqui.
No primeiro dia.
Rafa, se você quiser falar alguma coisa de ontologia, que eu acho que é uma das coisas que você trabalha bastante.
Pick a vontade tá que eu acho que foi uma das coisas que tá muito natural para você no seu dia a dia.
Você quiser falar alguma coisa importante quando eu terminar aqui.
Ai, C, acrescenta o que eu acho que é importante.
A galera entender o qual isso.
é isso? Entendas como isso é importante? Tá ligado.
Então saca só o Game.
Agora, em vez da Llm.
Pesquisar Api. E daí ela literalmente.
Baseado no reasoning dela. Em nenhum contexto. Whatsoever qualquer coisa.
Fazer um guessing games para você. Você tem que pedir evidência, pedir prompt assim por diante.
Por que essas informações não passam por uma camada ontológica?
Aonde ele vai descobrir durante essa camada ontológica.
Tudo isso aqui. Entidade.
Ele vai descobrir. Relacionamento.
Ele vai descobrir.
Regras e eventos.
E ele vai descobrir Providence. E tem várias outras coisas que ele pode fazer.
E esse conteúdo de coisas vão ser alimentados constantemente.
Para dentro disso.
E aí, amigão? Depois disso?
Você tem uma base completamente curada.
Aonde você pode entregar isso aqui via, por exemplo, Mcp.
No seus sistemas agênticos, ou para qualquer fábrica que você queira.
Entregar e a sua Lm: agora eu vou mais longe. Ainda tá.
E aí, junto com a Sueli Elieme.
E agora, junto com a Suely Aliene.
E junto com a Mcp, eles queriam. Sabe o quê?
Uma Atomic Task. Uma tarefa atômica de trabalho que pode ser executada por qualquer um Llm.
Esse é o grande questão.
Do rolê. Hoje, Rafa pode.
Acho que você pode falar mais algumas outras coisas legais.
Eu acho que você já falou praticamente tudo, né? Pô muito bem colocado.
Assim dentro de sistema. E ele dá sentido ao domínio para o agente. Então a gente tem algumas.
Traz Esse Entendimento Para Dentro Do Sistema Então Como O Luan Falou Ele Passa A Entender Quando Você Vai Em uma tabela, por exemplo, o que essa tabela quer dizer? E começa a fechar. Guarde rails para o sistema para o Llm trabalhar.
E ele, na verdade, ele adiciona pra gente semântica. Ele adiciona tipos, ele adiciona regras e principalmente, significados. Então, quando Você Manda Isso Para Um Llm E O Llm Tem Uma Composição De Ontologia Em Cima Dele.
Então ele consegue fazer essa correlação entre o que é negócio e o que é técnico. Isso é bastante interessante.
Coisa que eu acho muito legal é que ele reduz a liberdade.
Liberdade perigosa que tem. Então, por exemplo, hoje ele pode inferir o nome de uma tabela. Ele pode inferir algum Tipo De Documento Mas Com A Ontologia Ele Restringe O Espaço De Interpretação Que Ele Tem Então Uma Pergunta.
Ferramenta. Então ela vira uma ação dentro do sistema. Então esse é bastante interessante.
E.
Eu acho que, basicamente, o que gera para a gente dentro de todo esse contexto de engenharia genética.
Que você consegue conversar entre vários agentes com a mesma linguagem. Então, quando o Luan mostrar como você começa a Disseminar Tarefas Dentro Dos Agentes Você Está Conversando Dentro De Um Mesmo Escopo De Um Mesmo.
Domínio de linguagem. Então não tem o perigo de um agente entender uma entidade de negócios. Por exemplo, uma tabela. Vendas confundir isso com uma tabela de finanças, por exemplo. Então isso é bastante interessante. Ontologia tem exatamente para a gente fechar o sistema fechado.
No sentido de significado real do que nos.
Significado real do que a gente propõe para o Llm.
Ou seja, nem é tão importante em sistemas Enterprise, né? Rafa.
Só um pouquinho.
Não muito relevante, né.
E aí, obviamente, um gráfo. Não é um bei semântico.
Porque sem um D semântico, um agente pode entender relação.
Mas pode calcular uma métrica errada. Justamente pelo que o Rafa falou.
Justamente pelo conceito do domínio. Então a camada ontológica não traz somente as características, mas traz entendimento do domínio como um todo.
E isso é a grande chave do role. Isso que faz literalmente legal.
Eu já vou. Já vou deixar você perguntar. Deixa eu só mostrar demo, porque eu acho que vale muito.
Mostrar para vocês a demo de ontologia.
Então aqui, eu vou verificar se a ontologia literalmente, se o sistema básico simples que eu.
Tirei aqui. Ela tá up.
E aí eu vou mostrar para vocês aqui o que significa só para vocês darem uma olhada.
Obviamente que vocês vão ter que estar muito mais do que hoje para entender como construir isso. Mas eu vou Mostrar Aqui Qual Seria A Característica Como Um Todo.
Mas olha só. Que foda, Rafa!
Primeiro. Eu pedi aqui. Deixa eu começar de logo. Primeiro. Eu pedi para ele fazer um validate na Ontology Layer.
E depois eu pedi para ele explicar. Revenue.
Olha o que o Ontology falou para mim.
Transact status and resolved block it by business decision.
Awn financial honor mini.
A business metric that cannot be defined safely from physical table names alone.
Puta que pariu! Você tem da informação que não dá para ser.
Definido. Ou seja, você vai buscar isso com Stewart.
Cara. Olha só. A gente tem esse conceito de. Isso vai mudar a cabeça de vocês, cara. Vocês entenderam isso aqui.
A gente tem lá na nossa canela de ontologia, que ainda não está definido, o que significa um revenue.
Eles precisam entender o que significa.
Então, quais são os candidatos para esses inputs? Payment amounts paid ad total Order.
Quais são as decisões que a gente precisa para literalmente entender isso. Tá.
Quais são os pagamentos, se é reconhecido como pedido? Se era fulfillment.
Quais são as currencies e assim por diante. O que você vai ver no final do dia.
é que se a gente vier aqui dentro de Src. Transactico, Domains, e vier aqui dentro de Transactjon.
Essa é a grande ideia. Bem, simploramente falando, você tem uma entidade de cliente.
Hiperksimplórido simplório, tá? Você tem o nome? Cliente? Status evidenciado.
A fonte. Customer, identificador Customer, Id.
Descrição. O cliente do preço em Store e evidencia aqui. Mas você tem várias outras informações de enriquecimento que vêm junto.
Com essa camada ontológica. Então é o que o Rafa falou. Dá o entendimento do contexto.
E não somente isso. Faz com que os agentes possam concordar ali, nessas terminologias como um todo.
Para que eles não precisem de fato alucinar, ou que eles não aluccinem gigantescamente.
E aí, o que a gente pode fazer? Olha só. Que legal. Agora, com o conceito em mente, a gente pode.
Literally continuar na seção C que eu já tinha fechado. Aqui não tem aqui, ó.
E aí a gente vai falar para ele o seguinte: escreva somente.
Ontology lê a saída do transaction Ontology Explain revenue. Compare com histórias de Context sem executar.
E a gente vai ver, na verdade, que agora o que. Que a gente vai fazer? Ele vai lá ver O Contexto Que A Gente.
Trouxe um entendimento dele e a gente vai gravar a camada ontológica, o que realmente é o certo e pelo certo.
Pode perguntar lá.
Okay.
Vamos lá. A parte de ontologia.
Ele pega só o que é estático ali. Ou ele fica observando o sistema para ver onde vai. O quê? Porque Geralmente Você Tem As Relações Um Para Um Para Muitos E Tudo Mais.
Então, por exemplo, se eu for fazer engenharia reversa hoje do sistema.
é só rodar esse código no no estático. Ele fica lendo. Já deu algum erro assim? Sei lá.
às vezes. Tem alguma relação que não está muito boa.
Você pode escolher ser estático.
Sim, obviamente. Na primeira momento em que você executa essa parte de carga ontológica, que é a sua carga full. Teoricamente.
Você vai ter todo um processo de indexação. Depois tem várias técnicas que inclusive depois eu posso chamar o Rafa Para Falar Como Você Vai Fazer Isso Como Você Vai Indexar Isso Junto Com O Led.
E fazer várias coisas. E tem várias técnicas ali dentro.
Ou você pode transformar isso num Event Driven. Então, quando houver uma mudança significativa no seu sistema, você recebe um Evento Que Você Precisa Reindexar Ou Precisa Fazer Algum Tipo.
A grande característica é a tabela de pedidos. Essa é a parte legal. A tabela de pedidos é a tabela De Pedidos Ela Nunca Vai Mudar.
Nunca é uma palavra forte, mas assim, cara muito difícil ela mudar o que pode acontecer é o que você Falou Pô Tem Uma Nova Coluna.
fait.
CTLU schedule, vousette unobs, voceety un guma queues.
fort.
Altera, entendeu? Então você vai. Baseado nisso. Então você pode fazer tanto estático. E o estático já vai te.
Resolver, cara? Sinceramente, noventa, eu diria.
E os outros dez? Você literalmente pensar em qual a técnica que você vai fazer para o que você vai resolver.
Pode perguntar. André.
Você consegue se desmutar. Ainda.
Se não estás conseguindo, quando você conseguir, você me avisa, tá?
João, vê se você consegue ser desmotar.
Perguntar.
Opa também boa noite.
Boa noite.
Mas, você comentou em algum momento sobre estar usando o akf, que acho que é uma, espécie de llm week.
O Fkka. Aham.
Yeah if devem ser como é que funciona, não sei se vocês vai mostrar, isso em algum momento.
Cara. Assim eu uso ele mais pelo conceito de uma wiki atualizada e de uma documentação como um todo. Eu Não Vincularia Ele Como Um Processo De Ontologia Porque A Ontologia é Para Você Descobrir Significados.
E conceitos dentro do que aquilo significa para um domínio, para uma característica de negócio específico.
Isso é uma coisa. A ideia de documentação e de Wiki é mais no conceito de você entender o seu Repositório De Você Evoluir A Sua Documentação.
E que isso, de alguma forma, pode ajudar ali o seu.
A sua camada de ontologia, mas eles não são ligados. Pelo menos eu não vejo eles ligados diretamente.
Acho que são coisas que respondem.
Princípios diferentes. Tá.
Rafa, que é acrescentar alguma coisa.
Cara Pensontologia Nesse Processo Que A Gente Está Falando Como Se Ele Fosse Um Dicionário De Negócio Para O Trabalho que você está fazendo. Então a ontologia sempre vai ser ligada ao negócio. Então, como é que a sua tabela de vendas se relaciona Com Uma Pergunta Que Um Cfo Vai Fazer Por Exemplo.
Qual é a coluna que vai chegar e qual a descrição dessa coluna? Então você vai dar meios para o Llm Entender Essa Informação E Conseguir Processar Em Cima Dela Vai Ser Como Se Fosse Um Dicionário Em Cima Disso.
Perfeito.
Well, they'll have Caroline.
Boa noite.
Nossa. ótimo.
Opa boa noite luan o rafa, falou agora uma coisa que já matou a minha pergunta, cinquenta já que eu queria perguntar como funcionaria a antologia, para a refaturação de sistemas alegados então só pegando o gancho que ele falou.
Se seria um dicionário de negócio então, ela ajudaria muito para a refaturação sistema ligasse que é o que eu estou passando hoje na minha empresa estou, refaturando o cemitério legado e aí, quando falou de ontologia, que eu não ouvi falar só, descobri aqui eu falei caramba dá para eu aplicar, isso lá então, acho que é muito funcional nisso.
O meu projeto na cama. Eu fiz, baseado em termos. Então eu criei um contexto ontológico, e eu utilizo de, Literalmente Ele Para Fazer A Tradução Do Tsql Para.
Para o Python. Se usou como ontologia no seu projeto Rafa, sem abrir.
Foi Na Verdade Foi Exatamente Isso Se Vocês Olharem No Meu Linkedin Tem Um Paper Lá Falando Como é Que foi o projeto. Então a ideia é que eles queriam migrar mais de mil dashboards do Power Bi de um modelo semântico para um Modelo Semântico Unificado Maior Dentro De Um Naval Lake.
Então, a gente criou a ontologia de todo mapeamento do Lineage dos dados. Então da bronze, até a versão do Fabric Então Todas As Camadas Tinham Ontologia.
Nós temos agentes que fazem essa validação e faça migração automática desse Dashboard usando faz.
Usam agentes para fazer esse modelo. Desculpa, gente. Para o novo modelo semântico.
Então a gente usa outro exatamente dessa forma. Para fazer esses mapeamentos.
Ou seja, nem tão importante, só essencial.
Muito bom, Carol. Então esse problema que você está tentando resolver, existe uma forma de fazer isso ficar ainda melhor.
Ou seja, você já tinha os meses e já pensava como você ia fazer isso? Agora? A gente materializou isso Para Você Chamando Ontologia.
Então essa é a grande sacada.
Ayrton.
Opa consegui aqui está me escutando.
Ah, pode perguntar. Estou. Estou te escutando. Pode perguntar.
Vocês que aí, já estão na vivência do de a e tudo mais a gente sabe que as grandes companhias estão correndo atrás que nem a macroestrada está trabalhando, a camara semântica dela que está integrando com. O ia.
A gente tem aí o apache atlas que é para feito para essa, parte de ontologia como que está nesse fluxo aí de a engenharia, porque eu estou vendo aí, que vocês estão trabalhando, bastante em cima de macdown vocês estão criando uma nova metodologia para substituir essas, ferramentas.
Ou é um primeiro, passo. Eu fiquei um pouquinho confuso, assim no a visão de vocês para o futuro porque tipo, assim as companhias, estão investindo né então aonde, onde estaria o disruptivo dessa história.
Aonde seria interessante investir mais.
O disruptivo é que basicamente, é para que você construa uma ontologia. Você precisa do entendimento do negócio como um Todo Obviamente O Que Vai Acontecer é Por Ser Um.
Não é um termo recente. Na verdade, ele é muito antigo, por ser uma característica agêntica.
Recente, eu diria: o que muita gente está fazendo é experimentando diferentes práticas. Porque, como eu falei.
Eu acredito muito que durante muito tempo, a gente não vai ter nada canônico para essas coisas que são muito grandes.
To. Por exemplo, a data Brics resolve a ontologia, beleza, ela resolve. Ela quer resolver ontologia no contexto. Data Brics. Para esse propósito.
Para o propósito de como os dados dela são.
Colocados na infraestrutura, como que o dado chega para ela. Então ela consegue ter previsibilidade de como ela vai fazer isso.
Quando você pega um sistema Enterprise, por exemplo, que não vai ter data Brics, por exemplo.
Provavelmente você vai criar o seu próprio, seu próprio camada de ontologia. Ou você vai usar um atlas.
Ou você vai usar alguma coisa que já existe. Então.
Na verdade, não é reinventar absolutamente nada. é só mostrar.
Que ontologia é um conceito, então você pode tanto usar numa ferramenta como você pode implementar a sua.
Como você pode utilizar a data Brics. Então meio que é só mostrar mesmo as características.
Do processo. E o que é de fato.
Ayrton.
Ô, patamovil.
There is!
Eh sempre foram participo aqui parece que eu estou no, futuro alguns clientes que eu atendo.
Cara é outra realidade. Mas efetivamente na empresa mais high level que, eu estou alocado.
Tem muito o sistema legado e assim para, mim trazer esses conceitos tudo que a gente está abordando aqui, acho que tem pouco, a ver até com a pergunta da caroline.
Como é que seria, em áreas, com definições conflitantes por exemplo de clientes receita inadimplência qualquer estratégia, prática para construir um consenso sem bloquear, a evolução do negócio.
Cara. Eu acho que assim, pelo que eu tenho visto nas empresas, eu já passei por sete empresas diferentes, tá.
Recentemente empresas médias, grandes e grandes.
Na minha opinião.
Vai acontecer de baixo para cima e de cima para baixo. Mas o que é determinístico é a cultura da Empresa E O Entendimento Que Ela Tem De Hoje.
Yeah.
Não adianta você querer trazer ontologia se o cara, porra, ele nem sabe por que ele precisa de ontologia. Ele Nem Está Passando Pelo Problema Ainda Entende.
Então, por exemplo, quando eu converso com um cliente com uma Radiance, por exemplo, Analytics.
Os caras já os caras já estão, tipo assim, cara.
A gente está construindo uma fábrica em que o usuário cumprir a intenção dele.
E daí? A gente cria um Spec de Event Development. Gera um documento, coloca o artefato lá. Depois a gente Traz Um Multiharness E Traz Isso Tal Tal.
Só que a gente tem um problema. Que a gente tem um contexto fraco. Quando o cara.
Ele pede informações específicas.
Eu não consigo identificar aí, porra.
Ontologia aí o cara. Ah, faz sentido. Por quê? Eu já estou aqui agora imagina, você não tem nada. Você Fala Cara Vamos Construir Ontologia.
O que serve isso? Tipo, então assim é muito gradativo. Do que você falou? Dos estádios, do fato de eu Estar Aqui Onde Eu Estou Falando Para Vocês.
é porque eu preciso disso. E por isso que eu fui impulsionada. Estar aqui, apresentando.
Talvez você não precisa agora, mas vai chegar uma hora que eventualmente, claro, em algum projeto a fazer.
Aquilo vai ser uma sacada para você. Mas eu acho que é o ambiente, como sempre falei. é o ambiente Que Vai Fazer Com Que Você Explore Esse Tipo De Coisa Não Diferente.
E nesse estágio aí que você tá, tem que ser de cima. Não adianta vir de baixo. Ah, galera, olha só.
Aprendi como utilizar Dark Factory.
Tá? Mas os caras não têm noção nenhuma do que você está fazendo. Tipo, porra.
Entendeu Não Adianta é a mesma Coisa da Conversa Do Seguinte. Você Está Usando Yao Para Trabalhar Pô Todo Mundo sabe que todo mundo hoje usa Iá. Até porque se você falar com alguém que não usa Ia, você vai falar, caralho, bicho. Como assim, velho.
Hoje. Eu estava conversando com o meu funcionário na pívia.
Vocês não vão acreditar no que eu escutei. Ele falando. Não só abrir aqui dois minutos.
Eu falei, cara, a gente tem trezentos procedures para fazer. Como que você está fazendo.
Ele. Eu estou criando um script em Python.
Eu falei. Você ou a gente? Ele não. Eu.
Eu estou há, sei lá, três semanas fazendo isso.
Cara. Abre o Cloud Code.
Então, assim exatamente está demitido.
Hoje. é esse nível que a gente já tá cara. Então assim.
é triste porque.
The Scene.
Hoje, a gente tem empresas que são grandes e que a galera não entende nem o que é prompt para Você Parece Que é Mentira O Que Eu Estou Falando Mas Não.
Eu vou às vezes conversar com a empresa. Que beleza. Os caras estão no estádio zero.
Mas exige pelo menos uma.
Uma moção para ti. A já tem empresa que o cara está no zero e ele acha que a Ia é Burra Porque Não Funciona E Tal Então.
Você tem que desconstruir isso para construir. Então é uma parte Ayrton Sul muito mais cultural.
E muito mais de soft.
Na minha opinião, do que de hard.
Descaso.
Beleza. Vamos lá. Vamos terminar.
So about no.
Beleza. Isso, vamos falar.
So queria complementar assim eu tenho.
Eu estou, colocado em, quatro projetos, geralmente eu lido ali direto com o cliente.
E, assim é absurdo por exemplo a gente está aqui estudando coisas que são? Né lá de fora são? Coisas high level.
E.
Eu fico acho que a grande pergunta é quando, isso vai chegar no brasil porque.
Top.
Eu tenho um cliente. Por exemplo que eu fiz análise de imagem é uma construtora fiz uma análise de imagem da obra e a, dá quantos, por cento aquela obra está pronta em relação a quanto o usuário informou para ele para ele ver que o, usuário está mentindo e lá.
Chamar os pedreiros e enfim coisas desse nível ele, desacreditou que era possível.
Fazer, isso.
Tipo assim cara, do brasil, tem muito parece que acho que a gente, vai surfar muito numa onda assim absurda na hora que começar a evoluir aos poucos.
Okay a gente está vendo aqui.
Assim. Tem muita empresa que já está nisso. Por exemplo, vou dizer uma coisa bem chocante.
Eh.
A Nubank chegou lá para o time inteiro e falou: cara, não existe mais dados, né? Morreu agora todo mundo é Soft Em Dinheiro.
E porra, beleza. Então a gente está falando dado no bem que tem, sei lá quantos times especial de dados, seiscentos, setecentos pessoas.
Em dados.
Cara. Muita gente vai ser demitida. Muita, porque é difícil se adaptar. Eu acho que eles ainda escrevem Closure.
Para melhorar ainda. Tipo, ainda é uma linguagem de programação mais.
Complexa para aprender. E isso está acontecendo, cara, eu vejo várias empresas também. Então, assim a galera já está com A Ideia De Corte De Custo Do Que Usa De Como Reduz.
Essas empresas que ainda não se adaptaram.
Ayton, eventualmente. Você já sabe o que vai acontecer, né?
Meio que não tem muito o que falar, porque.
A inovação está vinculada muito hoje à velocidade e qualidade. Você consegue fazer o dois hoje você consegue inovar rápido E Você Consegue Fazer Com Qualidade.
Coisa que você não conseguir. Esses Acts. Eles eram completamente.
Diferentes, cara. Ou você botava qualidade, ou você botava velocidade. Não tinha como fazer os dois hoje.
Você faz os dois velocidade com qualidade, então assim podem.
Deixa. Eu só complementar uma coisa aqui que você falou para o Ayrton. Ayrton tem uma característica que a gente Não Leva Em Consideração O Que Você Está Vendo Aqui Que O Lan Está Trazendo Para Você é Muito Primeira Mão Então Tem Muita Gente Lá Fora Que Não Está Aplicando.
Isso. Uma coisa que você tem que considerar.
Sim.
Falou. E voz, principalmente parte de confiabilidade de sistemas, sistemas, engenharia genética. Tem muito pouca gente, usando, pelo menos nas Empresas Que Eu Trabalho Então Assim Tem Muita Coisa Que Dá Para Chegar.
Muita coisa que está vindo de muito primeira mão aqui, trazendo aqui no Academ. Então isso tem que pensar.
Exatamente.
E aí você já se alinham para saber o que está acontecendo.
Isso é muito bom. Que está preparado, né?
Vamos lá! Vamos lá.
O que eu posso falar de sistemas agênticos para vocês, tá? Então o que está acontecendo nessa área?
Eu vou dividir aqui em cinco grandes características, né?
Obviamente, quando a gente fala de chás longos, então a ideia é que a gente tenha.
Chats menores.
Passes entre chats, ou seja.
Que a gente tenha contextos mais.
Eu diria não menores, mas com textos mais.
O melhor qualidade. Eu diria Isso vem muito do contexto. Isso vem do tipo de memória.
Ter evidência capturar evidência, uma grande característica. Hoje, muita gente está começando a falar, por exemplo, de tracing.
Três, na verdade. E toda essa rastreabilidade tem que ser do dia um.
Autoridade. Então, como que você.
Quem você, né? Quem? Quando você está no looping ou não estar no loop?
Como que você entende falha. Isso é um outro ponto muito importante. Pô, não é só o caminho, né?
Certo, mas como você entende, falha e como que você julga isso?
Então você tem um sistema que julga. Você tem um gate para julgar. Como que você faz esse tipo de coisa.
Porque quando a gente pensa no processo.
Qual é a grande mecânica de um sistema genético? é exatamente isso que você está vendo aí na tela.
Você tem primeiro um objetivo.
Olha só. é só pensar.
Você tem um objetivo.
Esse objetivo.
Preferencialmente, vai buscar um contexto que a gente já viu. Pode ser um Second de Brain. Pode ser um arquivo no repositório.
Pode ser ontologia. Pode ser os três.
Daí. Ele vai lá, cara, quais são as ferramentas que eu tenho acesso ao meu terminal? Aquilo que eu posso fazer.
Depois ele vai observar o ambiente. Com todas essas informações que ele coletou.
Depois disso, ele vai literalmente coletar evidências e ver o que ele realmente considera que é certo ou não.
Depois ele vai verificar com voz, que é uma das coisas que o Rafa vai falar esses dias.
E depois, obviamente, é importantíssimo que você tem para esse tipo de coisa. Até que você sinta confiança de colocar Isso Num Gate De Um Vol.
Você tem um ano para cara. Faz sentido. Então eu falo muito de a fábrica autônoma, né?
Então, para quem vai fazer o booticamp comigo daqui duas semanas?
Sabe muito sobre para você chegar na Dark Factory no nível cinco.
Você tem que passar pelo nível um, dois, três, quatro, cinco ou pelo menos pelo três, quatro, cinco.
Porque Dark Factory não é literalmente um toggle que você habilita ou desabilita. é um dial. Você vai aumentando, cara.
Pô. Fiz tudo isso aqui para Indulupro. Fez isso aqui tudo pô beleza. Agora automatizei esse loop beleza. Agora eu Saio Desse Cara E Vou Para Ele.
E daí? Eu vou fazendo isso. E daí? Eu gero um artefato, esse artefato. Ele volta para dentro do contexto. A gente tem.
Esse ciclo sendo totalmente habilitado. Essa é a grande sacada de você estar na mecânica do processo agêntico.
Que é exatamente essas características.
Um ponto muito importante para vocês levarem em consideração. é telemetria.
Por exemplo. Olha o que a gente vai fazer aqui. Agora.
No seis.
A gente vai fazer o quê?
A gente vai basicamente criar.
Um documento técnico. Então, olha só. Se a gente começar a pensar. A gente consegue traduzir todo.
O processo.
Em destilação técnica.
E essa destilação técnica pode se tornar o quê?
Pode se tornar algo em que nós possamos utilizar e canonizar o que é canonizar. Isso.
é literalmente transformar isso num processo.
Então aqui no cinco.
Gente vai fazer a trajetória do agente visível. Então, aqui no seis.
Acompanha comigo que a gente ainda não chegou no ápice. Tá.
O que a gente vai fazer aqui? Vocês sem executar novas consultas ou ampliar a investigação.
Resumo, a trajetória da sessão em exatamente seis eventos. Jason.
E a gente vai colocar isso.
Trace dot Chasing. Cada linha deve conter timestamp bases e assim por diante. Ou seja.
Aqui. Eu estou mostrando que quando a gente constrói um sistema genético, qual a grande característica aqui.
Injetar três, injetar. Teg Metria.
Para que a gente comece a entender o que está acontecendo dentro do sistema. Para a gente começar a pensar Como A Gente Vai Desenhar Os Próximos Passos.
O que vai no looping, o que vinha no Evol? O que não vira, o que é importante considerar para Aquele Processo Que Você Está Construindo.
O que não vale você considerar.
Então, o que a gente vai gerar? A gente vai.
Gerar para cada pedaço que ia acontecer.
A gente vai gerar uma observação. Vai gerar um processo.
Tá? Então tres vai servir justamente para isso.
Então, se a gente entendeu até agora.
Você tem um problema.
Esse problema vai ser criado.
Documento ou Documentos de Entendimento.
De negócio desse problema de negócio vai ser.
Criado um documento que pode ser criado um documento técnico.
Que explique o que é.
Aquele problema que era de negócio, o que era técnico para a gente poder resolver. Ele.
Então aqui a gente vai continuar na mesma sessão.
Eu já vou colocar aqui.
Próximo passo é a gente pegar todas essas informações do contexto que a gente colocou aqui.
Está vendo que a gente está fazendo passo a passo, né?
Então a gente criou a informação de contexto.
Para achar as evidências da informação, para realmente saber o que é o valor que o Cfo quer.
Depois a gente foi na ontologia e pesquisou essas informações para ter ainda mais essa âncora em informação completa. Em relação a isso.
Agora, a gente gerou um documento de investigação aqui.
Olá.
Que legal. Que mostra mais ou menos uma ideia de quando foi feito. Quantos tokens foi feito e assim por diante.
Então isso ajuda a gente a entender a característica do sistema. O que ele fez, assim por diante.
Aqui. Eu estou mostrando pessoal. Só os abstratos, tá? Fica tranquilo que durante a semana a gente vai encapsular tudo isso.
Em esquios em clá em processo. Enfim.
Eu quero que vocês entendam os elementos de fundação.
Que é o que importa, tá? E aí? Olha só. Ele gerou um arquivo de Brief técnico. Olha só. Técnico Brief.
Olha só. Que legal. O arquivo de técnico Brief. ó.
Pending Human Review Review Remains Unresolved. Olá, ainda. O conceito de Revenue não está resolvido.
Ele somente traz informações que buscam o contexto, buscam teologia.
E busco tres para poder trazer mais informações.
Quanto de vendas foram feitas ontem. Quais são as evidências.
Quais são os. O que a gente encontrou? Quais são as decisões e questões que a gente tem.
O que a gente vai entrar no Gate quando a gente entra. Então aqui a gente está construindo um entrelaçamento técnico do requisito.
Para o entrelaçamento técnico.
Está criando essa sequência.
E aí, obviamente, o que a gente vai fazer agora?
A gente vai consolidar essas informações e tentar achar soluções em cima dela.
Então a ideia é a gente consolidar tudo isso agora.
No próximo card. O que que a gente vai fazer aqui?
Bem. Aqui a gente vai para a nossa sessão sete.
Que é o quê?
Tudo que a gente fez nos leva a ter uma. Skill. Olha que foda.
Bem, a gente tem uma prática manual.
Que a gente testou vários processos de entender, refutar, questionar.
Depois disso, a gente literalmente viu que a gente pode repetir isso várias vezes.
E isso vai transformar um requisito técnico. Para o quê? Para um requisito. Desculpa, um requisito de negócio para um requisito técnico.
Isso pode ser o quê? Uma coisa canônica.
é daí que a gente cria uma Skill.
Então, uma Skill. O que ela pode fazer no sistema? No seu sistema.
Ela pode criar algo extremamente utilizável. ó Leia Skills Interview the System.
E aplicam este para investigar como a transactico pode responder. Qual foi sua receita ontem? Porque o Cfo deveria confiar na resposta.
Use o texto que a gente criou.
A ontologia que a gente fez e o térreo cobrife como contexto aprovado é presente o Grill.
E o contrato proposto em uma única tabela, no máximo oito linhas. Aguarde confirmação antes de usar a ferramenta.
Caralho. Calma aí. Então, na verdade, a gente está usando o sistema.
Para o nosso favor. é a gente está coletando todo o prompt, o contexto, a informação, a ontologia.
E criando mais que o para responder esse tipo de problema.
Isso é o que uma fábrica autônoma faz. Vocês estão aprendendo os constructs para a gente construir. Olha só. Que foda.
Então vai muito mais de uma decisão. Vai muito mais de uma informação.
Olha lá, Lias Skills.
Lesq e os três aspectos em investigação física já está feita. Aprovado. Existem dois candidatos. Esse é o número ou esse tal.
As informações. Você falou, deve confiar porque a resposta era uma definição decidida por finanças aplicadas a evidências reconciliadas R Quatro Zero Zero Tal Tal Tal Tal.
Beleza. Vou chegar aqui.
Contrato confirmado. Faz muito sentido.
Executo somente as verificações de leituras etárias para continuar a atualidade. Escreva o pacote.
Esse que o preserve. Revenue como decisão humana não resolvida no chat e responda como, no máximo, seis bullets.
E aí a gente vai validar aquela informação.
O que uma fábrica autônoma com o que a gente chama de Flywhew.
Vai fazer para você? Ela vai fazer isso?
Ou seja, vocês viram uma fábrica.
E alguns componentes dela sendo criados na sua frente.
Tem um problema. Questionar o problema.
Achar contexto evidenciar.
Escrever isso, chamar uma camada de ontologia que já foi criada.
Daí criar um arquivo técnico do arquivo técnico, entender que você tem toda uma transmutação do entendimento. Problema, resolução, evidência.
E você cria uma esquio para resolver aquele problema.
E são faio eu. Ele vai aprender com as suas lições.
Isso é um dos componentes da fábrica.
De uma fábrica de um looping. Muito bem feito.
E aí a gente começa a confiar.
Na fábrica, né.
Então, olha só. Que legal. A execução.
Gera uma lição que está numa memória.
Que criam mais Skill, que faz melhores agentes. Muito foda, né? E aí você cria uma flyw.
A fábrica aprende com o processo. Então, toda vez que ela executa, ela fala. Cara. Quais foram as lições que eu já aprendi.
Legal. Carrega as informações importantes. Foi embora para resolver aquele problema.
Quando ele bate num problema, ele coletou todas aquelas informações e eventualmente cria uma Skill com evidências.
E fala, cara, eu vou geralmente seguir para resolver esse problema. Se ele tem alguma dúvida, ele coloca um mano no loop.
Humano. Estou criando essa Skill para fazer isso. Isso o que você acha? Tal tal tal beleza?
Aprovou esse Skill.
Comentou. Próxima vez que ela roda e vai bater nesse mesmo problema no baixo que tem uma Skill que já resolve aquele problema.
E a fábrica continua girando e aprendendo em relação a isso.
Na última Live. Eu tinha falado, mas não literalmente.
Entendido isso. E qual a grande mensagem do dia de hoje?
Entender, controlar, especificar, verificar e aprender.
São os componentes da roda que a gente vai construir ao longo dos dias.
A gente entendeu. Qual é o problema? A gente para resolver o problema principal. E agora a gente vai começar A Construir O Harness A Gente Vai Construir Especificações As Tarefas Atômicas.
E vocês vão ter na quarta feira. Quem estiver aqui.
Acesso ao Task Spec, que é um projeto privado.
Em que vocês vão ter acesso a consumir.
Uma unidade de tarefa clonada via Cli.
Então simplesmente você só chama esse cara e pede para ele criar uma tarefa. Ele vai literalmente gerar uma tarefa Para Você Com Todas As Validações Com Tudo Que Você Precisa Em Cima Dele.
Esse aqui é o componente mais atômico. E mais importante que eu tenho de todas as minhas fábricas de componentes.
Que vai servir tanto para a semana como vai ser também pedaços do que a gente vai construir lá no Booticamp Que Vai Acontecer.
No dia vinte e quatro. é daqui duas semanas.
Aí já construiu um sistema realmente produtivo.
Para isso, tá? E vocês vão ter acesso a esse cara.
Beleza. Vamos lá. Quinze minutinhos de perguntas para não acabar tão tarde.
Quem tiver dúvidas, levanta a mão.
E a gente vai com tudo.
Primeiro. O que vocês acharam aí? Coloca no chat.
Aprenderam. Qual foi o momento, foda o que vocês.
Tiraram do dia de hoje.
Me. Fala aí, pessoal. Saber o que foi?
Top.
Sim, vocês vão ter acesso a esses slides. Eu vou colocar dentro do repositório. Tudo vai estar lá.
Luciano, Opa.
Pode falar, Luciano.
Boa noite luan.
Boa noite.
A gente passou por algumas ondas primeiro libera aí.
Faz o que, quiser, cuidar a ia ficou cara.
Agora a ia está sendo, controlada e agora a gente, está num momento de.
Mediu o roi em cima do, desenvolvimento tem algo que vocês já usam para.
A gente justificar ali o roi de uma entrega por exemplo de um filks.
De tudo, que está sendo, desenvolvido.
Cara. Eu acho que isso ainda. Essa é um ótima pergunta. Eu acho que isso ainda é uma coisa em Fluxo Ainda Acho Que Muito.
Tem como fazer. Tem, mas eu acho que isso é uma coisa ainda muito.
Muito específica.
Por exemplo, quando?
A empresa tem uma ideia.
Do que ela precisa entregar.
E ela entende qual o problema que ela tem que resolver. E ela entende financeiramente que ela não consegue fazer isso.
Com as guias normais. E você apresenta esse processo agêntico.
é fácil de você, literalmente mostrar o porquê. Muito fácil, mas muito fácil.
Agora, na maioria das vezes, ainda não existe esse.
Essa informação seguinte, cara, olha só, você tem cinco pessoas aqui.
A gente vai criar uma fábrica. A gente vai criar um processo, agente, que vai fazer isso e você vai ganhar.
Turkey. é difícil mensurar isso ainda. Porque, cara, tem custo de llm. Como você falou.
Tem o tempo de, de literalmente criar essa solução. Você tem que, uma vez que você coloca uma solução no Ar A Gente Tem Que Manter Essa Solução.
Viva. Então a grande questão é.
Ainda é difícil, mas é algo que está exatamente em pauta.
Exatamente algo que está acontecendo agora, nesse exato momento.
é descobrir como que a gente mensura.
Tanto. é verdade que, quando a gente olha hoje, quais são as conversas, por exemplo, na empresa onde eu trabalho, Nas Empresas Em Que Eu Faço Consultoria Enfim.
A galera está falando cara. Como que a gente.
Como que a gente consegue.
Literalmente quantificar, né.
Essa informação do que é literalmente a Iad, como a gente entrega, por que a gente tem que acrescentar a Iad Nossos Processos Enfim.
Porque é o que você falou. Muita gente fala. A gente já passou por vários estágios, mas hoje a gente Está No Estágio Que Eu Diria Que é A Consciência Enterprise.
é o que eu digo, porque antigamente, todo mundo utilizava Ia.
Mas era uma coisa de baixo para cima, né? Então você acelerava o seu projeto.
Sendo colocado no Card lá, que demorava trinta horas. Mas você fazia muito menos. Você acelerava várias coisas. Você conseguiu Fazer Várias Coisas Ao Mesmo Tempo E Assim Por Diante.
Agora as empresas já entendem porque todo mundo diz: Ai fala, cara beleza. Agora, como a gente contabiliza, Ia.
Porque aí tem vários problemas em você. Fazer isso primeiro. é um mundo completamente novo.
Segundo, a gente não sabe.
Nada do que vai acontecer com Tokens.
Aumento, diminuição.
Briga entre os modelos Frontiers. Enfim, a gente ainda não sabe o que vai acontecer.
De uma coisa eu sei. é bom para o consumidor final.
é bom para o consumidor final. De alguma forma.
Que a conta vai chegar, cara. Eu acredito que a conta vai chegar em algum momento.
Mas não no que a gente. No que a gente no que eu. Escuta aí há uma bolha. Vai deixar De Existir Não Eu Acho Que A Pergunta.
Isso é um mundo sem voltas. Absolutamente não. Tem como se voltar para uma era anti ar assim eu não consigo.
Pensar que seja algo diferente disso. Muito fortemente.
Mas muitas coisas vão mudar completamente. A gente tem muitas coisas do modelo local.
A gente tem várias máquinas mostrando isso. Agora. A Apple acabou de lançar o.
Blaster de Ram local. A gente consegue colocar isso dentro de unslot. Ai consegue colocar o Química tres.
Muita coisa vai mudar nesse espectro. Mas eu acredito que essa resposta da Enterprise vai demorar muito tempo. Ainda.
De ter uma resposta realmente canônica para estar. A gente mede dessas formas. Aqui isso se torna padrão para todo Mundo Medir Os Seus Projetos.
Isso vai demorar.
Eu não sei quem foi que colocou a mão primeiro, mas todo mundo vai responder. Então tanto faz.
A Live pode falar.
Opa, como que vocês na pifel estão vendendo isso, ou os clientes estão chegando em vocês.
Ou não sei se você conversa bastante com o pessoal do comercial que eles vão na empresa, demonstram o que Está Acontecendo Até Você Comentou Uma Vez Que Estava Indo Nas Empresas, Empresas, Fodas E Tudo Mais.
Sim.
Você consegue compartilhar isso? Porque eu gosto de criar os vídeos do Linkedin lá. Esse pessoal já viu e tal.
Sempre falam de alguma coisa assim. Para eu começar a demonstrar.
Boa é hoje? Porque eu estou, né? Não sei se isso é uma benção ou uma maldição. Eu considero como benção.
Mas hoje eu estou trabalhando direto com o escritório do Cto. Então.
O que a gente faz todos os dias, todas as horas. é o que o Field citou da Pf. Faz. A única Coisa Que Eles Falam.
Eles recebem prospects.
De sales dos funils de sales.
Funil de seus identifica o seguinte cara.
Esse cliente aqui. Ele veio perguntando de Iá.
Ele veio perguntando aqui. Pô.
Vocês já fizeram alguma coisa de aço? Vocês já utilizaram Ia na Google? Quais foram os casos de uso que Vocês Já Fizeram Assim Por Diante Pois é Um ótimo Candidato.
Aí. Ele manda esse funil para o Office Cto.
Aí. O Cto recebe essa informação, que é o Paul Lewis.
Ele fala, cara Jeff, que é o Field.
Faz uma apresentação para esse cliente, mostrando os nossos casos de uso, por exemplo, em.
Desenvolvimento. Aí ele vai lá, mostra, pô. Fizemos isso nesse cliente. Traduzimos tal por causa disso disso disso. Mostra lá O Que Ele Fez Realmente Por Que Ele Agilizou.
E mostra ládio os porquês.
E aí o porquê vai exatamente no coração do problema.
Qual o problema do cliente? Pô o cliente queria isso. Vai ter muito. Tá lá? Mas isso vai ter muito.
O cliente quer modernizar o ambiente dele.
Todo cliente vai querer fazer velho todo.
Pô. O cara quer migrar de um sistema para o outro. Todo sistema. Todo cliente vai precisar disso. Ou ele Vai Precisar Migrar Ou Ele Vai Precisar Modernizar Todos Sem Exceção.
Para poder habilitar a Ia para ser Ai First. Para ser Whatever. Ele vai ter que imigrar beleza.
Ah, yeah, Peace, vai lá e fala, cara, qual era a dor do cliente? Pô? O cara tinha um legado de S. Kelly.
Um prêmio estopado que pagava duzentos mil dólares de dinheiro. Pagava dois, cem mil dólares de.
De licença. E aí eles queriam expandir o Sql. Mas aí eles queriam fazer Ia. E aí o Ceo vê Todo Mundo Usando Ia E A Empresa Dele Não Tem Ia Só Que Para Transformar Ia.
Ele tem que literalmente fazer essa moção e tal, tal tal. E custava isso e tal. E aí, o time De Consultoria Estimou Que Para Poder Migrar Tudo Isso Aqui Demoraria.
Um cinco anos com dois milhões de custos e a gente foi lá e fez por seiscentos mil dólares em seis meses.
Utilizando engenharia genica assim, assim. Pronto, bom, é isso.
Fomos no problema, destilamos problema expandindo a dor e explicamos como resolvemos.
Então a ideia é a seguinte: é você tentar atacar essas dores mais latentes, tipo, o que é dor canônica? Eu Estou Muito Tipo Falando Canônico Toda Hora Mas.
Pesquisa cara, o que é uma dor que toda empresa vai passar nesse mundo de a.
Cara não tem como ela vai passar por migração.
De alguma forma, ela vai passar por modernização de alguma forma. E ela vai ter que tratar o dado dela De Alguma Forma Não Tem Como Fugir Disso Ela Vai Ter Que Consolidar O Dado Dela Em Algum Lugar.
Ou oferecer mecanismos para que os agentes pesquisem informação.
Para fazer determinado trabalho para ele. E acho que daí já são suas.
Suas clubes para você começar.
Cinthia, pode perguntar.
Toghi davi.
Okay.
Estou Chumbing isn't it.
But.
Boa noite.
Meu, pifou faz um tempo já? É só para perguntar sobre a ontologia você vai detalhar mais durante a semana.
Ô isso vai.
A gente vai falar de ontologia durante a semana. Um pouquinho mais. Pode ficar tranquilo. A gente vai descer esse topo.
Nesse caso vocês trouxeram uma tabela pequena e tal mas trazendo que a moça falou a caroline falou sobre legados, e se acaso hipoteticamente tiver uma tabela que tivesse setenta colunas e tivesse colunas como objetivo.
Aí. Quem vai desempatar essa informação? é o usuário.
Alguém vai ter que ter o conhecimento para poder te falar.
Para a gente construir essa camada ontológica para essa tabela.
Nós temos essa pergunta. A tabela orders.
Ela tem uma coluna committed underscore, um committed underscore, dois committing underscore tres.
E você precisa de alguém que descreva o que essa informação é. De alguma forma, você vai achar no sistema.
Or. Você vai achar no back end, ou você vai perguntar para alguém.
Enquanto você não tiver essa informação.
Essa tabela fica.
Unavoidage or a voyage, por exemplo. Ela não é consultada. Então, se algum agente for lá pesquisar, ela vai ter Status De Por Exemplo Not Ready.
Ela não está pronta ainda para ser consultada. Via ontologia.
Porque ela não tem a descrição e informação dessa antologia.
Thank you obrigado.
Ou você consegue fazer diferença pelos dados também? Só complementando.
Não é possível.
Aí já vai mais. Aí já vai mais mais negra do que o Rafa fez de entender o contexto do Significado Do Conteúdo Da Tabela Em Relação A Isso.
Ou seja, Cinthia, dúvidas. Pergunte para o Rafa.
Sobre ontologia.
Ele fez muita coisa sobre isso. Muito.
André.
Cara, tá cada dia que, passa mais minha mente, fica explodindo aqui, tá difícil de acompanhar.
Eu queria saber na questão de entregáveis essa ontologia vão ser markdowns e quando você está desenvolvendo com o cláudio mas se na.
No órgão que você por entregar o serviço você vai o cloud, fica lá ou cria se um agente python ou, qualquer outra linguagem que vai, ter star factory.
Como que fica a entrega quais artefatos que, realmente vão para o cliente ou vai ficar, somente lá com a empresa da consultoria como que, está funcionando isso eu estou sem conseguir visualizar sabe, a questão de entrega o que, é produzido.
Você quer explicar um pouquinho como vocês fazem? Ou, tipo, como se os artefatos.
é, na verdade, no nosso caso específico, no meu projeto, que eu estou hoje, ontologia faz parte do projeto. Então Ele Não Vira Um Artefato Ele Vira Um Reggae Mesmo.
Nós temos um projeto que é baseado na verdade.
Nenhum produto da Microsoft Graph.
é Um Projeto Técnico Que Eles Desenvolveram Então A Gente Pegou E Fez A Implementação Em Cima Disso A Gente pegou o projeto técnico e montou ele basicamente dentro de um Regg. Então ele é um Graph reg transversal que monta toda essa estrutura Ontológica Para Que Os Agentes Consigam Conversar E Fazer.
Mapeamentos Então Ele é Um Pouquinho Mais Complexo Na Verdade Ele é Uma Pipeline De Dados Com Vinte E Nove etapas com processo de enriquecimento. Aí ele valida, dado valida. Ele vê quais são os dados, quais são a distribuição dos dados dentro de cada tabela.
Os nomes. Gera uma hierarquia de relacionamento de relacionamento para coluna.
De colunas para tabela de tabelas para sumários. Então eles geram uma quantidade. Então nosso entregável, na verdade, hoje, nesse Sentido Ele Não São Documentos Market Ele é Literalmente O Reggae.
Ou seja, ele tem as fontes.
O banco de, dados vetorial.
Isso. Ele tem várias fontes.
O baltudo. Não sou.
Pode falar.
Não Só Um Banco De Dados Setorial Ele Tem O Vetorial Que é Onde Ele Faz Música Semântica Mas Ele também faz pesquisa de Bm vinte e cinco dentro de dados determinísticos, porque a gente tem que criar um Led determinístico de onde as Informações Estão Então Na Verdade Hoje Se A Gente For.
Falar em termos técnicos, nós temos dois índices com dois índices vetoriais, mas nove catálogos determiníticos dentro de um pós Do Db Tudo Isso Para Montar Essa Estrutura.
Ou seja, resumindo, pensa o seguinte.
Thank you? I have one documentar devagarzinho.
Se tem as fontes de dados, você tem esse extrator que pode, sei lá. Pense num Python ou que seja Um Script Pega Essas Informações.
Coloca dentro de um vector. Mas não é só no vector. Tem um cosmos e tem outras.
Outras fontes para enriquecer. Então, quando ele pesquisa via Mcp, o Mcp enfim, redireciona para ele as informações do que Ele Tem Que Pesquisar.
Rafa.
Exatamente. Então.
é mais ou menos assim.
O processo. é exatamente isso. Como tem várias fontes. A gente tem os ingestores que puxam de determinados n fontes. Aí ele joga Dentro De Um Banco De Dados Canônico Canônico Do Luan Que Ele Faz A Deduplicação Do Dado.
Ele Gera Ele Começa A Gerar Provenância Dos Dados Nesse Momento Aí Ele Faz A Distribuição Dessas Informações Em Tipos ou seja, se você está falando de Linux, que você precisa ver como é que o dado se comporta ao longo do tempo, por Exemplo Dar Bronze Para A Prata Dá Prata Para A Gold Por Mais A Gente Monta Isso.
Então A Gente Consegue Depois Fazer A Pesquisa Semântica Então A Gente Vetoriza Essa Informação Que Ela Foi Enriquecida Por Llm a partir de uma série de regras específicas. Depois que isso tudo está pronto, a gente gera projeções. E essas projeções têm adaptadores Que São Os Mcps Então Os Mcps Na Hora Que Ele Bate No Adaptador.
Ele Sabem Qual Projeção Que Ele Vai E Puxa A Informação De Onde é Que Ela Esteja Então Ela Tem uma série de stores ali dentro que ela pode puxar a informação. Então, como eu falei no nosso caso específico, a ontologia é o produto.
Da verdade. Ela poderia ser.
é. é um produto.
Ela é o produto. Então ela poderia ser um Mark down, dependendo de como você esteja entregando. Mas no nosso Caso Ele é Um Pouquinho Diferente.
Obrigado, Raf.
Bacana então o que a gente está aprendendo com o luan hoje é o papel que a gente desenhava o nosso mer né.
Ou, seja a gente vai trabalhar com o mark down mas, aí no, futuro a gente evolui para colocar numa persistência melhor no cosmo que é o no sql no vector db organizado sendo retroalimentado por um llm é isso.
Isso exatamente, na verdade. O que vocês estão aprendendo com o Luan aqui, e que vocês vão ver ao longo do Tempo é que na Verdade a gente está Voltando Para Um Papel Onde A maioria das pessoas Vai Saber Um Pouco De Tudo.
Só Que A Gente Volta Muito Para Dentro Da Análise De Dados Então A Análise De Dados Ela Virou O foco de tudo isso. Então está falando de vol? é análise de dados. Você está falando de ontologia? é análise de dados. Você vai Ter Que Sentar Realmente Entender O Dado Para Conseguir Montar Essa Informação.
Espeque, análise de dados.
Então, na verdade, boa.
Guilherme. A última pergunta vai do Alad, tá.
Guilherme. Pode perguntar.
Right.
É primeiramente boa noite luan boa noite rafa é cara, primeiramente só fazer um comentário aqui eu vim da semana databrics dois tá e aquela semana ela praticamente mudou a minha vida cara, que dentro do trabalho eu consegui implementar muita coisa trouxe muitos insights e agora com essa evolução da ia.
Eu vim aqui buscar mais conhecimento e cara vai muito de, acordo com o que acabou de falar na pergunta passada né que atualmente o que eu fiz eu peguei um consolidado de notebooks que eu tinha, no meu ambiente cara eu consolidei todo o conhecimento dele na llm a gente conseguiu fazer.
Ele me recomendou fazer markdown né, eu perguntei se seria interessante fazer em reg mas ele falou cara você não vai escalar isso ainda, você está fazendo local você está fazendo pro seu trabalho que seria pra mim pra mais um deve. Então ele falou cara vamos manter mark down por enquanto que vai ser interessante pra você também e mais pra frente você pensa, em evoluir cara vocês estão falando isso aí exatamente agora então eu vejo que faz todo, sentido também a recomendação.
Mas cara eu passo por muito problema exatamente com esses valores porque eu trabalho como tributário cara então pensa no tributário a gente trabalha com nota fiscal a gente trabalha com fd de, cliente e cara muitas vezes é um desconto muitas vezes é recalcular o, pis recalcular o cofins.
Noss.
Recalculava icms aí tem desconto tem que, saber o que, tem ast ou que, não tem cara isso influencia muito muito mesmo. Mas, cara essa ontologia cara ela deu assim um.
Expandiu minha mente agora sabe ela expandiu a minha mente como sempre é com os cursos aqui com você mas, cara, é interessante eu estou, ansiosíssimo para os próximos passos mas cara insano tá insano mesmo, valeu mesmo, pela aula cara.
Que bom. Bom. Você vai conseguir sair e dormir agora daqui a dez minutos. Só que não.
Não vou eu não vou isso é certeza cara, isso é certeza eu, não vou já tô até com o databrikes aberto aqui cara já? Tô? Fazendo alguns, testes aqui.
Tudo graças principalmente àquela semana databrics cara valeu mesmo.
Tudo graças a você.
Beleza. Valeu, Guilherme.
Só uma coisa aqui. Para quem está falando tanto de Mark Dowell? Galera, vai atrás do Okf open knowledge format.
Esse cara vai ser. Eu acho que isso aí vai vingar muito para quem gosta de mexer com o Macdown e quer.
Transitar informação, tirar reggae do caminho. Muita coisa tem muita coisa legal para surgir com isso. Aí.
Bye. Vai, vai! Também acho.
última pergunta. Vamos ládio.
O que é possível fazer com seu ensinamentos e tudo mais. Como é que vocês estão fazendo? Qual que é O Teu Contato Com Esse Pessoal De Marketing Vendas.
Mora lá. Foi comentado aí do que entregar para o cliente, até porque.
Nunca. Você vai ficar sem um lock in, né?
Mas os entregáveis para o cliente. Até você pode falar. Ah, para o cliente. Se você quiser sair daqui.
Dá três anos a não sei quanto tempo e tal imigrar para outra.
Claro que isso é novo. Tudo está acontecendo agora e tal. Se o cliente gostar do teu produto, ele vai continuar contigo. Enfim.
Como é que está sendo isso o que eu entrego? Porque vai ter o lock in do vector Db. Vai Ter Várias Coisas Assim Como é Que Está Funcionando Isso.
Eu acho que isso não, Mud.
Eu acho que é o que você falou. No final. Você vai estar alocado em alguma coisa. Tem muita coisa. Open Source Ufk E Cara.
Tudo o que a gente falou que dá para criar, viu? Só se dá para criar.
Dá para ser vendor neutro. Dá para ser vendor específic.
O que eu tenho visto é que.
Não diferentemente do que a gente escolhe. A galera vai muito nas cloud. Então pô. Vamos supor.
O cara está usando aws, cara. O cara vai num bad rock. O cara vai na Stake, ali da Ws Pra Tentar Representar Ele.
Ele usa ali? Talvez um gateway de conectar até no Cloud via Bedrock ou coisa do tipo.
Então eu vejo que as empresas têm a tendência de tentar utilizar produtos que estão na nuvem.
Mas a gente já viu que tem vários produtos que estão fora. Então, por exemplo, pegar um Vector Database.
Geralmente estão fora. Bons virtual databases. A gente pega para falar de Subscriptions.
Muito delas estão fora também. O Cloud realmente pode rodar por fora.
Então eu acho que não muda muito.
Eu acho que o que muda.
E que eu acho que ainda não está muito.
Na visão da empresa. Hoje.
é que a forma de criar mudou.
E aí, com a forma, mudando.
Muda se os meios.
Os meios de criar e de trabalhar têm mudar.
Então, uma das coisas que a gente vai sofrer muito nos próximos.
Eu nem falo mais anos, né? Mês, anos.
é a forma com que a gente vai trabalhar.
Por exemplo, que não Rafa. Assim pô todo mundo vira analítico.
é mais pô qual porcentagem da galera que de fato é analítica.
Você trabalhou numa empresa chinesa.
Será que todo mundo entende o que significa analisar realmente passar tempo mais tempo analisando do que de fato.
Mais tempo codificando fazendo coisas. Então essa visão analítica parece idiota, porque a gente é engenheiro de dados. Já tem Essa Visão Analítica Já Normal.
Mas não todo mundo que tem essa visão analítica. E isso vai doer muito durante muito tempo. Então, pô o Engenheiro De Software Precisa Ser Mais Analítico.
O cara que é cientista de dados. Depois tem mais analítico. O Iml Engineer Analítico. O Devops Cara precisa ser Mais Analítico Também Porque Tudo Converge Com O Dado.
O deployment da infraestrutura para o dado e assim por diante.
Eu acho que muda a forma. As tecnologias não. Sempre vai ter o vendor sempre vou estar ali.
Azul. Então você está pagando dentro do azuleiro para fazer isso para você, entendeu? Então.
Eu acho que isso não muda. Muda a forma de como você vai chegar no meio.
Beleza. Bem, espero que vocês tenham curtido, né? Primeiro dia, a gente tem aí uma semana inteira de conteúdo.
As gravações ficam disponíveis. Acho que até meio dia do dia seguinte. Então, a galera do time de.
Tecnologia vai subir essas informações amanhã de manhã. Quando eu acordar, eu vou subir o transcript, coloco lá para vocês. Tá Até Meio Dia Vocês Podem Ver Lá.
Inclusive eu. Já deixei aqui que vai estar lá.
Estou anotando.
E aí vocês vão ter acesso ao transcript e aos slides, tá? Que vão estar lá dentro da.
Do repositório. Beleza.
Então, pessoal. Até daqui a pouco, abraço.